three two
well here we are again
every friday just like we said we would
be h3 after dark baby we never missed
shoot we're all met baby
or a brick good luck we'll find out in
the world you know
when it slams into the rim it's a brick
yeah yeah um
you know my dad whenever i watch ucla
games this is a total
that's like i always found this so cruel
college uh basketball
ucla every time when an opposing team
comes
and there's a thing called an air ball
that's when you totally miss the basket
the rim it's nothing yeah
so every time that guy gets a ball again
the rest of the game they go
airball they [ __ ]
[ __ ] on him the whole game brutal
nice brutal
how's everybody doing on this beautiful
friday
um afternoon ela my co-host
beautiful as ever looking fresh is
absolutely
[Applause]
looking fresh as my ass after a nice
squirt on the bidet baby
what a compliment well i don't know what
else is fresh
name something fresher than that right
eddie fresh dirty fresh fresh as a teddy
um how are you today uh good i
yeah it's been i'm actually
what no i i i'm sorry i thought the same
thing
what it's been said either you looked at
me
but it's in a visit i'm sorry shrek
music
it is that's uh that is um what's their
name a bear naked ladies right
but did they make shrek songs uh
they seem like the type of band that
would i don't know if they're in my head
that i think of as shrek music which is
like rock where they talk really fast
rock and roll
it's been 10 tracks that you shrek swat
it's been 10 swamps that you shrek that
me
anyway so i was gonna say
[Music]
that it's been a tough week
of lots of teddy fresh work so
i'm kind of like my brain is a little
bit of a mush right now
but we are we worked on like something
really
cool for later this year can't talk
about it
so we finished designing it and i'm
really happy with it but
um it was it was really great that i was
actually fully focused on teddy fresh
because there was so much to do
but it was also weird to um it's like a
big change in my life i feel like
because you're there you're in the
office you have like yeah that's a ceo
right no um
we had a room there was like a photo
photo shoot room
and we painted it all black on dennis
advice
and um now that's my office and i'm
sitting in a black room
which i'm sure is really good for your
mentors yeah
so you visited blocked oh yeah
right every day that's my office every
day how does it feel to be black dealer
i feel like if you just walk into it not
knowing anything it looks like i'm into
like really weird stuff
yeah yeah well we're painting the walls
but you've been in full ceo mode i i
wish i we can't tell you guys about this
but you'll find out
about it towards the end of this year
but it is freaking
epic yeah but here's this is what's
coming out this month like next week
this is the classic it's a whole line
we've been working on of just like
classics beautiful
perfect nice inspiring quarantine
because we're all home anyway
and this is all we wear oh this is
quarantine it's fire interesting
and you guys can't see it but the zipper
is a teddy bear head
which oh
all right this is also coming out this
month right yeah anyway
that's that now i have a oh tom cruise
is calling in
today we have tom cruise the actor mega
actor tom cruise
we also are sponsored today by keeps and
expressvpn
tom cruise everybody legendary actor
it's gonna be calling in later it's
pretty interesting you know there's a
whole
phenomenon on tick tock where there's
like these celebrity
impersonators celebrity look-alikes
there's
a bunch of tom cruise ones so tom cruise
himself is calling in
to discuss this phenomenon and to share
his thoughts and what he thinks about
all these
how the hell did we land him yeah
amazing no yeah it's hey we're a big
show give brad [ __ ]
next yeah everything's possible when you
have a show this size and this important
well they know when we talk to the agent
i say look
listen i don't want to go to threats
but we have a very influential podcast
and i have seen tom cruise
wiki feat actually does tom cruise have
a work if you that's interesting oh
absolutely
he's already kind of hurting and i'm
just saying you know
the man has a reputation as a heartthrob
it'd be a shame
if somebody if somebody
did something bad to his wikifeed rating
you know they're not i want to smell
certainly not something we would ever do
no but i'm just saying
it sounds similar to extortion what
you're describing
yeah it does sound similar but but that
but you know
what is that yes yes i extort them i do
extort them what is that wait he was
barefoot when he went up there
yeah i guess he was on top of the burj
for some stunt and a mission impossible
but dude why where is that that's a
great that looks like a funny he's so
casual yep
because he has the power of scientology
that fuels everything he does yeah
these are some desperate ass foot picks
bro
you know what i mean how old is he tom
cruise man
there must be something to scientology
because this guy's pretty amazing it
looks like he doesn't age
yeah there's something to scientology
because if you look at this guy
he's 58 what no no way he's 58.
are you kidding me god yeah they're
doing something and scientology but it
only works for the i think what happens
in scientology is that they
somehow farm the
blood or the life force energy of the
normal
the casual members and they feed it to
tom cruise
yeah i do think they probably suck your
soul and turn it into liquid
right and then they fit it to him tom
cruise is definitely
what that's not what they do what do
they do
they cleanse your soul that's the whole
point okay
that's the whole point they cleanse your
school soul of cold they do cleanse
yourself they cleanse your skull
real good and they get the the there's
the things that people
have their skull cleansed by scientists
listen there's thetans which are the
souls of a dead extinct alien race that
have
glued themselves to our souls and we
need to
cleanse them with a e meter 58
or your balls anyway i said yes i do
extort them i mean i straight up
blackmailed them i'm not
like but what are they going to do take
me to court over wiki feet
so i says i'm gonna tank your [ __ ]
wiki fever don't come on our show they
said okay fair enough don't say no more
it's too important to our client's image
zach i have some out zach i was
listening to the last episode
since now i'm a listener um i
love the tulip discussion really
the tulip bubble he likes my little my
little tulip fart
yeah we talked we had this whole
conversation about the tulip bubble the
two
they were actually selling tulips i felt
like we concluded
that they were selling yeah i feel like
i didn't really learn anything well i
said that i said it
that's not that's not let's not revive
the tool of conversation please
we don't need to relitigate this please
i've moved on mentally
to tilly bubble it wasn't too the first
bubble ever
hula bart napoleon swam i mean i got the
facts man
[Music]
still debated
napoleon swam zach what is this i hear
about you hating peace and love
i don't like this what is this it's not
so much a sense of
you saying it or else saying it it's the
sense of like
you can say it and then say the most
hurtful [ __ ] thing after it
blank that's the joke that's literally
what's good about it i
but dan you said you'd back me up on
this yesterday
what well i i feel like it's it's half
of our comments on
on every social media platform and
youtube comments at this point and it is
it's a bit much it's a bit who are you
guys to pass judgment on what people
like
book stands out to people wait sorry you
guys
are already people who work on this show
and uh
and we're you guys are criticizing love
i think you guys are talking way out of
turn
yeah that's it
you're starting to hate peace and love
because people like it
i'm sorry zach was pretty passionate
about it yesterday on the zoom call when
we were prepping the show he was just
like i'm [ __ ]
sick of this peace and love it's every
comment is just peace and love
blah blah blah peace and love blah blah
blah can you give us an example of one
that
makes you mad yeah um
with peace and love i don't like abey's
hair yeah
i think i think that i think it was not
your hair i think it was exactly that
comment but
zack's hair so you think you that's
first you feel you're being insulted
more than usual by the audience
and they're they think it's okay because
they start with peace and love is that
what's happening you feeling more more
vulnerable lately
since the introduction
i i guess so i feel like if because you
say peace and love
people feel like you can say whatever
the hell you want after
like peace and power that's the power i
put it's like
no like like doesn't work like that
i mean i think it's hilarious when you
and eli it's just like
so zach zach wants to end state a rule
stating
fans with peace and love can no longer
say peace and love
only even with peace and love with peace
and love
interesting interesting i don't know
there was a lot of people saying aby's
hair was better than your sack
that's fine man i i like my i actually
look like you've
improved it i did i toned it i got the
purple shampoo i got a little haircut to
get rid of some of the dead
clippings on it but um yeah i mean look
people are entitled their opinion i like
it
i think i rock it and i'm gonna stay
good as long as it's not prefaced with
peace and love apparently they're not
okay exactly everyone keeps telling me
to tell zach about toner i've told him
with peace and love his hair is darker
guys oh so you're going to pull him out
now what is what
everybody's going on and on about toner
they tell me toner toner zac toner
taught her half of the comments
zach needs a tone ethan didn't tone it's
like just [ __ ]
stop with the toning i get it there's a
thing called toner and apparently it
i i don't care about toter i don't want
daughter i don't want to hear about
toner
i'm out on the toner and by the way the
minute i start toning my
hair no one can also talk about toning
hair
no no one can say pieces no pieces all
right what a great
any other boundaries they want to impart
on everybody watching
you know the minute i start toning my
hair and start to start trying to make
it look good then
then i've really fallen ethan has this
thing where he doesn't want to look like
he's trying
so he doesn't want to tone his hair
right
because it's not funny if i come out
look at with peace and love the ab he
wants to look good and that's fine and
god bless you know
why shouldn't you people like that you
look good you know i see people are
thirsting
for a b a lot in the comments with his
hair and stuff but like
it's just not funny like right now i've
got you like to make yourself look funny
it's not funny to come out and be like
all swagged out
it's not funny they need a pathetic
without a desperate old man
clinging to his youth very good issue
here
okay it's not i'm not using toner
because of the toner i think you need to
see a therapist no
it's funny with peace and love this is a
serious message to
everybody watching my update right
now peace and love
peace and love i want to tell you
please after the 20th of october
no more fan mail to any address
that you have i think i [ __ ] up i
think i missed the whole line
i missed the whole line
anyway uh we also have n
so okay you guys if you didn't watch our
last episode there's a huge thing going
on
with nfts we put up
our own exclusive one of i mean it's
only time this is ever gonna happen
art okay this is pretty serious now
this is a serious message please give us
your money
now we were taking bets on what would
sell stuff so this is pretty interesting
because we have updates
um by the way there's also a huge update
because when we did this bit in our
previous episode
the current highest selling art was like
6.6 million
now in between that time and this
episode the same guy beeple sold his art
for 69 million dollars one piece did
that just happen when
that just happened right after yeah that
literally just happened like yesterday
the day before
i think i saw that it was actually a
resale so it might have actually been
that same
six million sale somebody sold it no it
wasn't a resale
it was it was original piece it was like
a collage of his five thousand
works so was this guy
and actually i've been looking at his
art his art is really [ __ ] cool like
i'm not even gonna i can't even hate on
the guy
he's a digital chair yeah i've been
following him on instagram for
for a while and he he's always made some
pretty cool stuff apparently he makes
was he always into digital art yeah he's
always been a digital artist
apparently he makes a new one every day
which i don't know how the [ __ ] he does
that because they're like
really detailed um and so
what he did is he in the first five
thousand days he
made a collage of every single piece and
he sold it on christie's which is like
the most reputable auction house for art
for 69 million [ __ ] dollars bro
but like i mean how does he make this in
a day like they look
super good he makes this in a day yeah
he makes one new
every day what the world
because he's super rich obviously yeah
big artists do have assistance and stuff
but this just seems like way too
so these are digital
these are all digital arts that he sells
you know a lot of them aren't one of one
he'll make like a hundred copies or
something or a thousand copies in some
cases
but that one was one of one that's
really cool
but i kept but his art is super cool
it's like funny and weird
yeah just kind of [ __ ] up
you know yeah um really good excited
i don't know how he does it in one day
though i mean he must have helpers
this guy's eating out of turkey bro i
mean
that's pretty awesome
oh can someone like me the video of when
the sale went through it was pretty
interesting
he was watching live with his family as
it went through
um it was really cool the bowl the
bitcoin bowl
yeah i mean they're all like super
interesting there's 5 thousand of these
you know this one i thought was great it
should wreck
just [ __ ] paint you know what i mean
this is really what goes down in shrek
swamp
don't you make also paintings like real
kind of i don't know not that i know of
but i
certainly could be wrong on that i just
like the video too i would love that
this is what goes down
michael jackson and kim jong-un okay i'm
in
why not you know why not
oh that's a logo that's graphic
okay yeah i guess a lot of these are
pretty graphic
i sent you the video if you if you're
interested so here he is with his family
it's only like a minute long but it was
like in the last minute of the sale
this guy's like a normal dude with the
family and he's like yeah i just made
[ __ ] 70 million bucks
someone uh just said in the comment like
exactly what i'm wondering they said
people pl
paying millions for this but some people
can't afford to eat it's like
i also wonder like who are all these
rich people all of a sudden they have
so much money not all of a sudden it's
always been like this with dart
no but it's the specifically with the
nfl so this one wasn't actually an nft
sale i think this one was straight up
dollars because it was through christy
even though most of his stuff he sells
with nfts
okay but this was you can see it's not
in
the the currency that's being displayed
is literal [ __ ] dollars
i guess it still is an nft but you're
right that it was it was just
it was purchased in in they're buying
the nft sorry they're buying the ft but
it wasn't end like uh
crypto ethereum or something yeah it was
just straight up 70 million so
but still like who are they i don't know
that's so much money
yeah i agree people have always spent
ridiculous amounts of money on art i
mean no but all of a sudden you have
like listeners of uh or
fans of too mad right who just have the
money to splurge on a
well in a gag that's why we made our own
same question here yeah wondering like
who are all these i don't know so much
money
again back to the tulip we we were a lot
of us were speculating it's just some
crazy ass bubble
because well i'll explain like for
example the beeple one that
held the previous record was a resell so
people sold it for like 60 000
and then somebody got some guy turned
around and listed it
because like resale is really so and
then he sold it for
uh six million so i think there's a lot
of people that think that they can
resell this and make a lot of money so
that's one aspect of it
another aspect that i've heard is that
people
seem to think that this is some kind of
tax
tax evasion slash deduction uh
scheme you know which has long
been said to be one of the reasons why
people spend so much on art is because
you can value artists whatever you want
i mean if you buy
if you spend 70 million dollars as an
investment on art that's a full
write-off
but i don't really get that argument
frankly because
the only way that makes sense is if like
your friend it doesn't really
the only way it makes sense is if your
friend the person you're buying it from
is in on it
because you say here's 70 million
dollars you get to take it all off yeah
as a deductible well that's how money
but that's fraud
right that's not a tax deduction scheme
that's straight-up fraud
when i saw this piece sold for 670
million i was like you can buy
an original da vinci for that price
i just don't get it i don't know you
could buy
one of the grand masters all-time
masterpieces
for that price like there was or what
there was like an original da vinci that
was like uncovered
a few years ago can someone look up how
much that sold for i guess
also my immediate issue with it is that
like
what's the difference between me having
it on my phone
and like a screenshot or a jpeg or
whatever
what is the difference you know it's
just it's this weird new concept that i
think we have to wrap
our brands around it's the authentic
it's just
you own the authentic one
i know but when you buy an
an artist print you know it's a really
nice print
if you're going to go and print it and
uh well it's signed it's like signed
so let's say there's like 10 legit
lithographs signed by the artist so it's
like that i mean right but the print
itself
is also really nice quality if you go
and get a poster it's not going to look
the same
but ela you know if if a really famous
artist sells something
like a lithograph or something that's
signed even if it's really high quality
how much do you think that that print
itself costs to make you know at most
a hundred dollars maybe it's still being
the value is still mostly being derived
from the fact that one
it's rare and two it's signed by the
artist look i
i kind of that's where the value is
coming from it's it's super weird
and it's crazy like two matches selling
pictures of his titties for thousands of
dollars you know
idubbbz too he sold a picture of his
nutsack for a thousand dollars so i was
like let's get paid baby
yeah i don't oh okay so da vinci sold
for
okay sorry i'm way off da vinci's
original ela
that recently came out sold for 450
million
so that's a little bit more you actually
can't get an original
vinci for 70 million it turns out not
nearly enough money
what's the story with this when did i i
remember this thing came out
that someone found it like okay you
found it sounds like a fake to me but
okay
how a four i just found an article from
wall street journal uh
it was lost in america a louisiana
family discovers
uh salvatore moondi painting had long
hung in their home before it was
reauthenticated as a leonardo
masterpiece so
uh they had it and they just didn't know
it was real 150 million
can you show an image i want to see this
[ __ ] thing
it was sold in 1958 for 60 dollars
they thought it was probably a
reproduction or something or uh it's
called
it's called salvatore carlos loves that
investment
okay that's a bit connect whoa
because yeah so
so there you go i mean people's is a
bargain
here if you look in here it is that's
your boy jesus christ you know we love
you god
we love you i feel like i sound like
this
old people that are like they can't
understand why people
want to watch video games yeah like when
you watch a streamer playing video games
they're like but why would you want to
watch it i feel like i'm like that but i
just don't understand well listen
it it's far from alone in my opinion and
i could be wrong i could be eating my
words okay
but it's a i'm of the opinion that in 10
years and probably even less that
nobody's going to give a [ __ ] about this
[ __ ]
but again i could eat my words i'm just
saying
well ela there might be an nft that
might catch your interest
really just went up yeah there's a link
in the description just hit the
okay you guys know that we
each have our own and our nft ntf
non-fungible nft but did you know
how many of these did we meant dan or
ian 50
50 but only five are for sale right now
now did you guys know that we have our
own original
ela klein token that's right shredding
with shredder
she's escaping past the haters they're
doing ollies they're doing jumps that's
right it's one of a kind baby it's ela
cline
well it's one of 50. you have two weeks
to buy this
ultimate collectible this is the only
coin we will ever meant
this is your one and only chance um
and and whatever is not bought in two
weeks are going to be
tossed in the bin with peace and love
that's pretty sick i got to say so yeah
i like it
so that's so let me let me go over
because i think a lot of people are
wondering what's been happening
yeah now we put the okay because
listen this is all we don't know what's
going on and
i'm i'm hoping you guys see the value in
this more than us you know what i mean
because for us is just a gag so here's
the result so far
our vape niche coin we've sold
four wow we sold
four vape nation coins tokens
tokens we got the coins for the token
that's one etherium that's like 1800
bucks i mean with peace of love thank
you but
wow
but i don't know but that's the thing if
you're buying this you understand
something i don't
right because you can go turn around and
resell this [ __ ] rare
beautiful thing and make a bunch of
money apparently
yeah yes when i when and maybe i get
assassinated maybe i die in a car crash
the value is going way up you know what
i'm saying whenever the world is the way
it used to be
carlos probably bought one of those
coins he knows what's up he probably did
probably did
yeah when i was um explaining that we
were doing this to uh
a buddy of mine who's very into all this
you know i'm
you know i'm trying to understand it but
i am pretty skeptical of it but when i
explained it to him he was like oh no
people are for sure going to buy these
and they're going to he thinks people
are going to flip them and sell them for
way more than we're selling them that's
the idea that's how confident he is
yeah i'm like okay so do you say so i
think they will too because this is the
first
this is the one and only time this will
ever happen well i am kind of happy to
see that a lot of people in the chat
are also not understanding well i know i
want them to understand
they the majority of people i think are
very skeptical of this i do see um
actually that we did want to talk about
um people are mentioning that we should
talk about the environmental
oh we'll get to that but first let's get
to me getting paid i definitely want to
talk about that
let's come on ela well the people that
know don't care about the environment
they just want to get
paid hit me with that big connect big
good nerd
thank you carlos so guys let me tell you
i love
that's my boy
[Applause]
i feel like i'm on the big connect train
right now
okay so i haven't made it so excited i
already made
8 000 selling these [ __ ] vape nation
coins bruh that's just me
okay um now here's the tally
ian the legend himself five
coins to commemorate ian singularity
[Music]
five yeah
there's only three left e has sold two
of these
ian is in the bag secured the bag
we're talking almost four thousand
dollars that's to ethereum and what do
you have to say to the people
yeah well that's like the energy of a
small town or something really there's
the two tokens
thank you guys oh my god
let's let's bump that town up let's get
to a city come on baby
stand up we don't need energy in
whatever africa or whatever i don't know
who who needs energy ian please stand up
stand up please let's stand everything
up two tokens wow
two points i mean two coins excuse me no
no
you got a token no he got coins he's oh
he got that and he got two coins
okay that's okay i know what i'm talking
about
he got coins for his tokens what's not
clear about that
okay okay moving on to zach joker brain
give him a round of applause the boy
sold
one token for one coin
you're in the money baby thank you very
much joker brain
i just wouldn't get it dan with his
bridge to sell you
even in pewter
[Music]
even in a pure revolt of the notion
he even is making fun of the person that
bought it i've got a bridge to sell you
and yet despite his best efforts dan has
sold
one token
why why did you buy that somebody bought
it real quick why did you buy that
well they thank you what am i not saying
right i've got a whatever you should say
two
under what do you say close it
yeah does it not say too onerous oh yeah
it's because
the one person who bought it and us yeah
got it
they're saying boners why
uh a b the super set
has sold
one token everybody's in the money
let's go [ __ ] you baby
trista's not happy about it but hey she
doesn't have to buy it
so everybody sold one and sold two right
and
four free and i sold four does anyone
bought yours yeah
nobody spotted yet come on guys it's
been like
three minutes i'm trying to get paid
carlos is waiting
i feel like carlos right now so much
okay but this is the big prize
this is like people's five that first
out five thousand days this is
one there's only one of these legendary
[ __ ] bro
gold pulsating coin listen up watch the
gold pole say poof
watch that [ __ ] poof you see what i'm
saying it's epic
so it also includes not just the token
but the one and only vape nation full
video
nft the only one to exist
yeah it's crazy so we've had a few bids
i think it's a little far out
but like i encourage more bidding
obviously
you know what i'm saying for sure
um so i'm just so curious with these
people how can i see the bids because
they're right there
but i know there's only been three yeah
okay um
come on guys only three bids started at
one we're
if this doesn't sell for at least twenty
thousand i'm gonna be pissed
yeah so no no no
this is all very exciting so you guys
will update us right if there's any sale
any sales during the show especially if
elos we got to get on the map
got to get you the paid thank you thank
you oh let's watch people
[Music]
in yeah living room and we're watching
that's the legend
of the auction which closes in an hour
and 18 minutes
it's already at like uh absolutely 15
million
[Music]
every day three and a half years people
have created digital artwork and posted
online
so it's a collage of them all pretty
cool
can we use this music sounds like
uh what's it called some royalty free
shipping
i'll just mute it just in case well i
want to hear him talk yeah he's
influenced by the work of a bunch of
people in the crypto community as well
this is jason i just want to say
congratulations you're at 25 million 250
thousand
that's crazy 25 nearly one minute left
so there's one minute left it goes from
25 million to
70.
million so that's what i'm expecting
obviously for for ours right
i mean it's at a thousand now thousands
like or like 2
000 so i'm expecting you know the last
minute we'll probably get up to
20 to 70 million i'm expecting i'm
wondering if one of those people who are
buying it would want to call in and
explain why they're buying it
that's uh that's my dream i want to talk
to them yeah
all right actually if you guys are
listening now yeah if anybody who has
bought a
token a token not a coin you got it
hey um message zack
on discord we want to hear from you
mm-hmm i love these
yeah peace and love rate you dan don't
parade our callers i don't berate but no
i'm genuinely curious
dan's like let me [ __ ] talk to those
idiots i
am so excited i am so happy
i don't know though i'm feeling good i'm
feeling strong about that one
one of one one you know these are all
gonna be worth a lot someday for sure
apparently allegedly
well you either speculate now
you know get in now or you're going to
miss the train people used to say
bitcoin
would never reach what's it at like 60
000 now
uh it's going up there yeah
like 55 the other day
and that's what i wonder is if are the
only people buying this
the the crypto millionaires that you
know got bitcoin when it was ten dollars
and they just they have like half a
billion dollars now and they're just
like [ __ ] it i'll just spend money on
anything
that's what i think because it's like
funny money right they're like oh i have
like
that that's like i have a million
ethereum i'll just give you one
but it's still money you could they
could go sell that [ __ ] and just cash
out 200 million dollars i mean it's
money's money
people aren't just there's no such thing
as funny money you know what i mean
that's like oh i've got this uh i've got
these i've got a billion mexican pesos
so here's a
here's a million because i don't care
about my it's still money you know what
i mean it's legit
currency like you could sell it
and cash out immediately right dan
uh yeah yeah i know
you guys have said you know when this is
all said and done you're gonna
cash out this ethereum that we're making
i'm not keeping it
i think i'll probably keep mine you want
to get your coins i mean it just keeps
going up
you want to keep your ethereum coins
interesting
if it's worth ten thousand dollars next
year you know what i mean
i'm taking it out i don't want a coin i
don't want a purse
i need a coin purse you hear about
people losing their purse and then they
lose their money forever
really yeah oh yeah dudes who have lost
like thousands of bitcoins because they
farmed them a while ago and then they
like never
like yeah i heard a story of some guy in
europe who uh
who had bought a bunch of bitcoin in
like 2009 or something
and he lost the password and the thing
that he's using you only get five
attempts
at the password and he's used four so
now
he's like scared to do the last attempt
because then he'll get locked out
forever
carlos knows the password yeah it was
something it was like a hundred million
dollars worth of bitcoin in there or
something and if he
if he guesses the password wrong one
more time it's poof it's gone
how do you live how do you live your
life after that i think
you just have to
right i don't even know like you
literally burned 100 million dollars
just well
great so uh so we're at uh 36 minutes we
we got to do our
oh yeah all right let's see if he was
we said we would get to talking about
the environment oh oh
oh those are em creating them oh
ian's watching he'll let us know
yeah let's talk about the environment
well let's do the ad reads and we'll
talk about the environmental devastation
that minting these coins has wrought on
this world
um let's start with keeps let's thank
our sponsors shall we
we love keeps hit me with some cool
music so it's less awkward
yeah baby did you guys know
that two out of every three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they are 35.
we don't got to deal with that [ __ ] any
[ __ ]
more that's more than 50 million men in
the u.s suffering from male
pattern baldness yo we don't need that
[ __ ]
we want big beautiful tufts of hair like
we deserve
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medication delivered straight to
your door every three months
so you don't have to leave your house
which frankly i don't ever want to leave
my house for anything ever again
if you if you are using our sponsors you
never have to leave your [ __ ] house
again
you lazy [ __ ] but but it but it's a it's
a pandemic so
we have a reason all right this is how
you're gonna be feeling once you get
your hair back with keeps
oh let's go [ __ ] some weird chicks
what low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
you get it in a discrete package so you
don't have to be embarrassed
[Music]
although you shouldn't be i mean why
should you be
and it has proven results keeps has five
star reviews more than any of its
competitors
look they know that prevention is key
the treatment can take four to six
months to see results
so act fast and be patient
if you're ready to take the action to
keep that beautiful hair on your head
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
after dark to receive your first month
of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash after dark to get your first month
free
first month free keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash after dark
[Music]
one more we got one more to go here
fellas
oh keep that beat rolling will you can
you change the beat i like to change the
switch up yeah switch up this
one expressvpn so we need something a
little more like hardcore
intense intense oh there it is
here we go there it is you guys already
know
it's express vpn how could you not know
it's expressvpn
i talk about them all the time on my
show and i can't stress enough the
importance of protecting your online
activity
from big tech [ __ ]
who tracks buy a profit off of you
but there's actually another reason many
of my listeners also love using
expressvpn
netflix because you can
[ __ ] say you live anywhere [ __ ] you
netflix what's with all that crazy
i'm just feeling amped up because it's
us against the world you know what i'm
saying
it's expressvpn versus the world
see thousands of shows on netflix that
are only available outside of the us
so you all you need to do is change to
the country you're accessing it from
and boom bada beam you get all this
fresh new content
eat like for example if you connect from
japan all of a sudden it's like oh you
got the whole
[ __ ] collection of uh what's it
called the animator we love
miyazaki yes miyazaki yeah studio studio
ghibli it's like oh
okay what's up i said america not good
enough for studio
ghibli probably a licensing issue not
really anything
to do with nationality or anything but
boom experts vpn you're watching all
your favorite [ __ ]
same with canada uk there's tons of new
content up in that [ __ ]
expressvpn encrypts your data and
re-routes it through a server location
of your choice and not only protects
your data but also lets you control
which country netflix wants to
netflix thinks you're in you can choose
over 90 different countries so every
time you run out of stuff to watch just
fire up on your app and log in from a
different country
refresh and boom you've got new [ __ ] to
watch it's that [ __ ] simple dude
here's the best part it's not just for
netflix you can use expressvpn to unlock
shows or sports on other streaming
services too
boom you can use it on bbc iplayer you
can use it in the uk on all this netflix
freaking crap
piece of love i love netflix look
there's a reason why expressvpn is the
number one rated vpn provider by
published by wired cnet and more
importantly
me i love it be smart guys protect your
data and stop paying full price for
streaming services while only getting
access to a fraction
of their freaking content so visit
expressvpn.com
h2 right now and get three extra months
of their service for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 expressvpn h3 to learn more
[Music]
all right you want to talk about enviro
environmental devastation now
um
so the deal with that so we kind of have
a conversation about this
um it's like all the blockchain stuff is
super bad because you have to like
harvest is there some footage we could
look at
oh what was that video you sent me yeah
we should watch that
but basically there's just massive
[ __ ] servers that are mining coins
and running the servers and the services
um basically just
[ __ ] energy into the void for no
purpose other than this digital currency
you got that video that guy we watched
uh farming bitcoin yesterday and so it's
kind of weird for something that's
supposed to be like
new that it's not like
a smart thing you know that could also
benefit something so right you know when
i heard about the blockchain and the
farming
i figured that like they they were
crunching
algorithms to like that that somehow
that was make they were like trying to
solve
algorithms to create like ai or
something really interesting and
futuristic nah
it's just it's basically just running
the
servers the blockchain itself that
encrypts everything
um here's a video of someone doing a
bitcoin farming
operation it's probably somewhere really
cold like alaska
or iceland or some [ __ ] because the
server it gets super hot
yeah exactly so
yeah you can imagine how much energy
this is pulling so
this video is interesting but um
i looked into it a little bit and this
isn't actually the best example
for the wastefulness of it because what
this is
is they've built this using uh
um i believe it's when you uh
mine oil or drill for oil there's all
this gas that comes up
and it's usually just burned off into
co2 that enters the atmosphere
and they're using that they're capturing
it and using it to power
the server farm so this is actually an
example of like a relatively good way to
do it that's
well not sustainable because it's still
coming from drilling oil but that oil is
being drilled for all the other port
versus the
oil is drilled for anyways and it is a
good example of how much
power yeah i mean yeah this is yeah this
is not at all uncommon and i would
actually say that that's
relatively small there a lot of these
are
um you know in these data banks where
they'll have like thousands of
graphics cards running 24 7 like full
let's get some videos
yeah yeah okay sure you know look around
but yeah certainly yeah i mean i'm using
a lot of power i don't know what i'm
missing but like yeah they they mine
and then they run the and then they run
the
the blockchain whatever the [ __ ] that
means i literally don't even know
but apparently it's all encrypted so
they have to like crunch numbers and
should
to verify eight-year-old cryptocurrency
was established this is like the real
[ __ ] the last time journalist
there were tens of thousands of
individual computers this is where all
graphics cards are going
around the clock this is why i can't get
a new graphics card uh yes actually
i mean it's good it's a big contributing
factor to why
these [ __ ] are the reason why i
can't play video games
[ __ ] mechanical force of 260 washing
machines
this constant cool airflow is essential
to keep the computational hardware at
optimal working temperatures
that's because any burnout or
interruption to the mining process
literally costs money with individual
coins trading at many hundreds of
dollars
potentially millions are at stake so for
the technicians overseeing the enigma
facility
failure really isn't an option the
electricity bills at enigma reportedly
run time
okay y'all got just one graphics card
going spare i can use like we've been
waiting like how long for a [ __ ]
graphics card yeah we
upgrade our computer we ordered a really
uh i mean this is some [ __ ]
it's been delayed for about two months
because can't get the
[ __ ] graphics card yeah this pisses
me off i mean you guys are right is
pretty [ __ ]
that being said please buy my coins
there are other factors there was a lot
of
just like anything covet has disrupted
supply chains a lot in the last year
but yeah the crypto stuff is uh
definitely making
the graphics card market pretty
difficult
i just sent you a chart that shows how
much energy
it uses compared to a lot of big
countries
bitcoin specifically so this is just
bitcoin which i mean that is
the biggest one by far although
everything else combined is probably
like you know would make a double
so bitcoin alone has the energy output
equivalent to about
norway but right between norway and
argentina
which is kind of insane considering that
norway is like a very f
uh they probably use a lot of heating in
norway you know what i mean
china usa let's go baby
yeah and that so this is where people
kind of push back a little bit
um you know the advocates for crypto is
like yeah it uses a lot but
um you know in the grand scheme of
things i mean just look at how much
energy america uses
but obviously the counter to that is
like well those are for things that are
actually useful unlike
crypto would be somebody who's a crazy
the reason well i'm sure that the
energy cost per person us is probably
like way higher and super wasteful
compared to other countries but
you're saying a lot of that it's not
even about cost this chart is just raw
that's what i'm saying we we use a lot
more energy just because
we're america baby that's right but
um also america like you said is
producing actual
tangible goods in some cases where
bitcoin is like
setting fire to money right i mean
that's that's what somebody who's very
critical of this would
argue and you know this is an active
debate right now
of how much value it has really it looks
like all of the uk
produces like maybe
just over half double of bitcoin that's
kind of
that is kind of troubling consumes not
produced yeah just consume and that's
just
one coin that's just bitcoin right but
bitcoin is by far the biggest and
probably
the most power hungry as well and so
and also so either was saying you know
you think for like a newfangled thing
sustainability would be like a bigger
focus well so for a lot of them there
are because you know bitcoin isn't the
only one and there are a lot of these
other coins
and a lot of the ones that are trying to
compete
their you know philosophy
or ideology behind it is to make it so
it's not so damaging to the environment
and there are ways to do that and so it
i mean it's not
how can you do that though because it's
it's all about this so it gets really
comfortable
yeah it gets very complicated i don't
i'm not going to claim that to fully
understand it but can they use
more solar or something i don't know
well
that's what a lot of crypto people say
is like oh no you know most of this is
being powered by green energy like that
video that we showed an example of
i guess that wouldn't really be green
energy but that's still you know
using cycles it's recycled exactly and
so it's greener i suppose you could say
um but yeah i mean the truth is
ultimately
we need to move all of our energy to
green sustainable energy and so it
it really should just be part of a
larger conversation
i think it is kind of not silly
necessarily but
missing the point to focus so much on
the problem with this
where we really have you know a very
limited amount of time to move to green
energy in general not just for crypto
but for
all of our energy needs i mean when i
see this though it's like
are we really like there's tens of
millions it's like dude are we really
i feel like we're just not getting there
you know when we're having an ener like
uh
global crisis of uh changing climate and
this is what we're doing
right and that's yeah that's where the
criticism is coming from seriously
is is it's just like we're sort of in an
emergency right now and
and this is not helping um mm-hmm
but and also [ __ ] play video games
and these households are buying all the
cars that's the real problem that's just
some [ __ ] like
i'm sorry
those are not made to mine bitcoin
they're made to [ __ ] render my
graphics so i could see like good ass
looking titties in witcher 3.
like physics and everything bro daddy i
gotta jiggle
uh ian just dropped an interesting stat
uh he says apparently
youtube uses 10 million metric tons of
carbon dioxide equivalent
um i don't know what is that per year
i don't know oh that is okay that's a
good year and drop this
10 million metric tons of carbon dioxide
for all of youtube
entirely that means running all of the
servers all of the the data
centers and all that and now the entire
ethereum network
uses 12.5 million
that seems twisted that the ethereum
network which isn't even the most
popular coin by a long shot
it's probably it's the second most
popular yeah but like what's it at two
two i mean thank you for that zach but
anyway
yeah how does bit so how does bitcoin
compare to like youtube's output
you know what's their output uh
i don't know what it is in carbon um
exactly but uh yeah i mean it's a lot
more
than ethereum i think it is by far the
biggest consumer
i mean again it's in the top 30 if it
was a country it would be in the top 30
in the world
for energy consumption so yeah it's
horrible
you know but again you look at that
chart
and it's like please when you look at
that chart that i sent you
it's like yeah bitcoin you can
definitely criticize that
like i can't tell if you're ironic or
not i want them to buy my tokens i want
to get paid why
because i want to get paid what do you
mean why i get paid so bad
because it's hilarious i want people to
buy that [ __ ]
i mean what do you want me to do we're
selling it and talking about how
horrible it is and it's a terrible idea
so i need to at least
you know give it a little push like buy
my [ __ ] coins
bitcoin is uh 38 million metric tons
so almost four times as much as youtube
per year that's just
that is that is just disgusting
i mean i kind of feel like youtube oh
love coming in with some facts though
has a lot of benefits to society
and all well that's debatable
almost all electricity in iceland is
produced from using renewable energy
sources i've read that love that it's
like
from their steam ducks and [ __ ] right
geothermal yeah geothermal energy
so there you go maybe it's not such a
big deal after all
well i mean that's just iceland's a tiny
country yeah but they do a lot of mining
in iceland because it's cold there and
[ __ ]
bruh oh
yeah i was wondering i was missing what
the relevance of that stat was but that
does make sense
yeah so there you have it i mean
we could like solve the mystery of life
itself with that amount of graphic cards
you know what i mean we could find jesus
we could find the evidence that got it
is real
but i said we're buying we're mining
[ __ ] bitcoins
maybe that's what it's secretly solving
you know right
so anyway that's that has anyone bought
uh uh an ela coin yet
no wow i mean
how is that not even after that
incredible endorsement thank you oh we
got a new bid though
on the uh gold token do we really yeah
what's it up to
it's up to 1.3 excellent eth maybe
hey i just won like we should say people
that are getting upset about the the nft
thing specifically when it comes to this
whole environmental discussion
um the nft itself
isn't isn't uh specifically what's
causing the carbon emission it's it's
the underlying blockchain
as you said so are you saying that if
people would just buy nfts in dollars
instead of crypto then it would be fine
well it wouldn't really
work that way i mean you'd they are
there it uses the blockchain
the blockchain is how you're able to
know that it's authentic can i enter
the blockchain like the matrix if i'm
the chosen one sounds like a second one
maybe another like 20 years
into the blockchain give it 20 years and
you probably
can you know where i'm skinny and
[ __ ]
have abs that'd be sick i go in the
blockchain i have abs
where food doesn't have calories awesome
i want to be in the blockchain bro
you eat tokens you need tokens let's go
dude
that's why people want these freaking
coins so bad because they know when they
enter the
blockchain in ten years they'll be
they'll be on top of the world
what is the sick cyber music that you're
playing here is that
that's what it sounds like to be inside
the blockchain in the the blockchain
[Laughter]
all right um let's do let's do the tom
cruise tom cruise is waiting on the
phone right and i don't want to keep tom
cruise waiting he's a big busy actor
uh is he waiting uh let me oh he
actually is yeah yeah
okay so let's let's talk let's set up
this tom cruise segment a little bit
so on tick tock which by is my favorite
platform i love tick tock i'm on tick
tock it's my favorite
it's like talking about hold on hold on
sorry
started interrupting my home go ahead we
just sold anila
oh
[Music]
the energy that most of you [ __ ] use
in a whole year on one of those
eloquents did we really
i don't know
paid paid even though we just literally
gave the worst pitch
ever people are still buying it it's
interesting isn't it
it isn't we say it's wasteful don't buy
it it's a bubble it's going to be
useless it's going to be worthless in 10
years but they still buy it
please someone message that message if
you're one of the people that bought one
legit uh message zach
we're curious i was kind of hoping
people would buy like all of my coins
because i put up 250 they'd be like half
a million bucks
well dan you thought we weren't gonna
sell any i mean i would be happy
to crow a little bit yeah that's true i
did say that we went well that is closer
to
the reality than you are i said i was
hoping i didn't think i said zero you
said 250 yeah
i'm a little bit closer right but zero
i mean one is infinitely more than zero
so
you know whatever oh
oh hitting me with the the math facts
so we have tom cruise on the line big
star we don't want to keep them waiting
on tick tock there is a battling tom
cruises
okay so you have tom cruise deep fake
which looks incredible you know
look at this i thought at first i was
like oh my god tom cruise is on
tick-tock
it's the real thing
i mean uh
it's all the real
thing he's so good wait so what is this
exactly exactly that's not him
no they're all
what's up tick tock
you guys cool if i play some sports
[Applause]
i love it it's so good more for the
audio experience
as much as the momentum
hey listen up sports and tick tock fans
if you like what you're seeing
just wait till what's coming next
so the guy is like
[Music]
it's a little uh embarrassing you know
it reminds me i was once in the
russia i ran into uh gorbachev
he said you know mr movie star
are you nervous i said no mr uh mr
gorbachev
[Music]
well remember how much a polar bear
weighs i said polar bear
he said enough to break the ice
it's the last time i've ever seen macau
gorbachev
[Music]
so this is deep tom cruise on tick tock
he doesn't have a lot of videos only
four but he's making waves these all
have millions of views
magic you know so how is it
made it's just a deep like a super good
deep fake so the guy
um the guy is shooting the video you
think yeah he shoots the video
he's just does a super good tom cruise
and purse impersonation
and then he does he renders it with this
really good
deep fake technology that's amazing but
it's getting so good like you
you used to i wouldn't have thought that
it was him at first i really did i was
like oh what the hell is going on here
um but at first with the defects you
used to see like weird rendering [ __ ]
yeah kind of like in the matrix how
their faces like
no this one is perfect and uh it's good
because discipline
oh
oh my god
i think there's bubble gum inside there
[Applause]
that was incredible
how come nobody ever told me there's
bubble gum
incredible oh yeah
it's just the dumbest [ __ ] too i love
that
so that's deep fake tom cruise
okay now there's this is where the
friction comes in there's california tom
cruise on tick-tock
okay and he's the original tom cruise he
doesn't use defect
no oh oh well that's contested
now this is this is california tom
cruise
there's no technology here this is the
good old-fashioned
way right uh-huh so if you ever want to
see it again
ever if you don't do it you're fired
understood i don't this is california
tom cruise
if you don't do it you're fired
understood let me go to his page i don't
ever want to
okay let's see some of his uh hit i
wonder why he's got california
in his name that's so funny you know the
other tom cruise is getting a lot more
views so
like this guy's the original one but
he's getting kind of left behind
you know but this again california tom
cruise here he is outside people are
going crazy to meet
him no oh we can't there
we can't do that yet you know people are
they they're swarming him right he's a
celebrity out there but
this one seems to be stuck in the um top
gun
era hey san diegans the uss midway is
back open
come on down this is an ad did he just
get him ass
that's pretty cool i've been to the
midway ava
maverick here happy belated birthday
also was just doing cameos
cameos tom cruise is falling on hard
times
he's so invested in this topkin
character he's got the cars he's got the
motorcycle
he goes all in valentine stays around
the corner
do you want to try are you really using
that song and everything okay god bless
so this is once again california tom
cruise
who we have on the phone right now the
legendary
actor himself bring him in
let's see i'm so what i want to know is
how does he feel about
deep fake tom cruise who's coming in on
his territory
and kind of stealing his game here with
technology
um he wasn't born with the good looks
these are my i feel like he could step
up
california tom cruise oh uh you're
you're sideways for some reason
oh you're sideways i'm inverting
wow what an honor first of all let me
say sir
huge fan and i'm so glad that you're
here with us how are you doing
uh tom cruise doing great feeling young
you know
absolutely you look fantastic yeah thank
you
let me let me ask you you've been in the
game for a while
you're crushing it california tom cruise
you know all of a sudden you've got this
guy coming in
is that our guy from the east coast do
you have like a coastal beach
right well let me ask do you know who is
this deep fake tom cruise who's coming
in and kind of stepping on your game a
little bit
let me tell you i'm so annoying about
that guy
he's just finding out there's gum and
blow pops
right right and and the creator
he says it takes hours and hours to make
this happen
you know what takes hours and hours be
me right right right
sure well honestly nobody can out take
california tom cruise that's what i say
pretty confident about that
yeah it seems to be like you know what
they say you've heard of this phenomenon
where people dress up as soldiers but
they were never served it's like stolen
valor
do you feel like maybe he's doing stolen
valor a little bit
imposters right yeah yeah he's an
impossible no as long as i think you
recognize and you have the gratitude for
the people
in the service um i do respect these
people actually
as long as you don't um you know make a
fool of yourself
in the uniform right sure
have you met deep fake tom cruise i
wonder like is
dude what do we know do you know where
he lives like what can we do about him
i believe i believe he's in there l.a
guy okay
oh yeah oh you're you're california
he's coming into my danger zone that's
what i said right
right right of course i'm ready i was
born ready
on the fourth of july is there any other
tom cruises out there that we should
know about
like uh what feeling cut some kind of
battle royale maybe we could put you all
into a free-for-all type of situation
it's just me let the best man win
yeah absolutely as long as he does his
stunts i'm good
right he probably doesn't i mean what
what is his stunts eating a lollipop you
know what i mean
right magic tricks right exactly that's
not
i don't want to say the real tom cruise
because i don't want to all tom cruises
are valid
right i don't want to necessarily demean
the honorable workers
the first edition tom cruise first
edition yeah
have you met the first edition tom
cruise no i have nothing
really howard do you think he's avoiding
you maybe
he's probably intimidated yeah i think
he's too busy
you know oh he's too busy he's focusing
right now you know top gun maverick the
release
in a few months maybe flying to space
right i heard about that he's flying
this yeah
well you know i i think he's probably
intimidated to see
him his younger self looking kind of
just
i feel like he's you're probably a
little taller a little better looking
you know what i mean it's probably
intimidating for him to see you
who knows dangerous yeah dangerous right
oh no i'm looking forward to it maybe it
will happen i hope so
it's been a fun journey you know putting
a smile on people's faces and
just bringing back that nostalgia from
the 80s
you know um so far you know i'm focusing
on top gun but
i think i'll i'll bring it out a little
bit yeah
absolutely is this your full-time job it
is my full time
so where do you is it usually is like a
cameo thing by the way shout out to your
do you have a cameo right i want to
shout people out there
actually i do not have a cameo people
contact
yeah either on tick tock which is
california tom cruise
so they they contact me in dms and um
emails and that's
i'm just doing it like old style oh you
so are you avoiding cameo to avoid the
commission no believe it or not they
made it
a mission impossible to get on really
they won't let you uh your ass that is
outrageous they have no idea why
yeah you know why did they not allow
impersonators yeah do they not allow
impersonators is that what it is
no they do yeah what is going on this is
an outrage that we must
do you think i know people at cameo i'm
gonna get you on you think first edition
tom cruise is a part owner of cameo and
he's putting a block on it somehow
maybe it might be actually the owner of
deep fake
would that be
yo if deep fake gets on before you
i'm not gonna be okay with that i know
people at cameo how uh
uh california tom cruise we're gonna get
you on there okay
appreciate that yeah absolutely i'm just
gonna want us like a 10 commission
okay no i'm just kidding that's fine do
you need to
you know what i can get for you the blue
angels fly above your house
the most coveted of all tom cruise
memorabilia
well i gotta say i love your show oh you
do thank you
i appreciate that so when did you find
out that you had a knack for being tom
cruise i'm curious how this whole thing
came together
well actually from law backstory like
speaking about my past
um i moved from montreal to l.a
about 11 years ago and i went to ucla
and on campus
i heard every day you look like the kid
in risky business
i'm like okay interesting what could i
do with this you know i'm in l.a
i'm in architecture which is completely
different of
entertainment but you know it's um i
wanted to build that foundation here in
the states and i
i couldn't you know necessarily just get
an architecture just like that so
started street performing as maverick
and it worked well hollywood boulevard
um i did almost four years on the
boulevard you served in the trenches my
friend
yeah well you know frontline clean clean
polite and smelling good it works
yeah i i miss i miss all those marks can
you
like uh just say something like not
funny at all and then do the laugh
i just love the oh see that's something
deep does
this thing really good tom cruise yeah
he does pretty good yeah that's right
uh let me see just say for example uh
currency is devastating to the
environment yeah yeah
what do you think what do you think
about uh nfts and cryptocurrencies
well this is uh classified
let me ask you this how is dating while
you're
like like do you show up on a date like
how do you
dress to a date you know
i woke up like this i do this daily i go
everywhere
so do dates find it odd that you're like
kind of in character or i mean just
curious or do women find it
interesting or maybe they just like tom
cruise you know what i mean like you're
clearly a very handsome
guy do they want i think there's a
fantasy of like yeah
i think people don't
miss they missed their chance with tom
you know and they're like
oh my god so you think it helps so you
think you're getting more
more tail as a result of your occupation
you think wow like like a mega martial
literally right what
makeup
all tom cruise's lines fits and i could
converse
just using his lines from here right
do you have any thoughts on the infamous
volleyball scene where
a lot of people say that top gun was a
was a whole uh
kind of uh not parable what's the word
it's like a
it was a whole the whole thing was an
extended metaphor for being gay
oh the homoerotic undertones
of top gun okay yeah well i couldn't
tell you about that
right right no comment on that one yeah
no comment
that scene is wild though have you has a
girl ever slept with you just because
they're like i
want do do they ask you to be in
character tom cruise has that ever
happened to you
during a sexual encounter
[Music]
that never happened to me i'm able to be
myself
okay yeah that's a shame
why is that otherwise i would be the
canadian psycho
right i think yeah i think them you're
indeed all right
with me without me
well here's here's what i pledge to you
today california tom cruise first of all
i'm gonna get you on patreon
because you deserve it i mean not tay
john cameo [ __ ] patreon
unless you want to be on patreon i could
probably up but you don't need my help
cameo yeah cameo will help
um that's first second of all i am
pledging not only do that
i'm going to assassinate the the real
tom cruise that you can take his place
i'm going to be taking him out as well
as deep fake tom cruise
so the only people who doesn't seem as
enthusiastic about it there can only be
one yeah and then hopefully you could
just slide into his place and nobody
will even know
i'm advocating for you basically as best
as i can
well i appreciate the support you know i
i do have a career because of the real
tom cruise
okay it seems you don't want him dead
rather you
you're just a supporter and an admirer
of his right
i am yeah just a you know normal fan
yeah
right seems okay um i saw someone ask
would you get on only fans
oh only fans helm i haven't got none
on that either do you know what only
fans is
probably a lot of potential there yeah
yeah yeah
i think it goes a little beyond my uh
my uh yeah right there yeah
yeah right wow that's i keep my eyes
wide shot for that
oh we love it
all right well i will i am going to get
you on cameo you mark my words mister uh
very much all right well we're going to
keep an eye out for deep so we want to
execute deep tom cruise but we want to
keep real tom cruise alive right
one debt one hit only one hit
okay one hit one shot right one shot
all righty honestly honestly
you know he brings publicity he uh a lot
of people thought i was him people
thought
that was a deep fake so good or bad
publicity
as long as people are talking about tom
cruise yeah tom cruise is good for
business
let me ask you this he's probably going
to be close to retiring soon we just
looked it up he's 58 does that scare you
58 yeah now it doesn't scare me it
doesn't scare you
no no he's a tom he's a
he's a tom capsule i was going to say
time capsule yeah i mean if he retires
you're still
i wonder if that even put you i might
just run a little faster than him
exactly yeah i want to send i want to
see you in space bro i want to send your
ass into space
you deserve it well you know i'm on the
phone night and day
with nasa exactly yeah
doing some risky business i swear yeah
all righty
uh california tom cruise on tick tock
and soon to be on cameo mark my words
thank you for calling in you're doing
god's work you're doing a really
important work out there and we love
we love having you on thank you all
right take care appreciate you
thank you cheers guys
thank you man that was great we got the
real talk i mean
i mean fantastic you didn't see
i guess maybe he didn't appreciate the
insinuations that i would kill tom
cruise
uh yeah i think understandably
right well i'm not gonna kill tom cruise
right he would [ __ ] me up if i tried to
do anything if i send an assassin to
kill tom cruise he would like
he would like talk he would get him to
flip right
because he does all his own he's just
all of his own stunts persuasive bro
he'll flip him out tom cruise could
definitely kick your ass ethan
of course what are you what i'm not
doing i'm agreeing with you yeah
oh i'm gonna message cameo right now
it's a it's an abomination that the man
can't be doing
cameos yeah what does that mean i don't
know why
[Music]
there's another tom cruise on cameo oh
for
real tom cruise wait no it's his name is
not tom cruise on cameo
the online yeah
so i wonder if they're just thinking yo
this market's a little full
saturated why should it matter it
shouldn't matter to them
i think this guy is he good maybe this
other not tom cruise character
not as good as california time that's
what i figure how could you be better
than california
let's bump him let's bump not tom cruise
get him out of there
yeah kick him off cameo and get
california in there well
i i apologize if my i apologize to
california tom cruise and my comments
were
on uncouth you know i just remember
watching that movie one where he had to
kill all the replicas of himself to
become the true one
and so i figured you know all these tom
cruise out the world this is just a
crowded space
you remember that movie i was about to
say the jet lee movie
yeah i thought you were referencing a
tom cruise movie at first i was like
what the [ __ ] is that
no there's just there's too many tom
cruises in the world you know i mean the
world is not wide enough for so many tom
cruises
right so true it's not true for the
world
but i know i i'm calling off my
assassination attempts on all
other tom cruises okay all right so i've
got a
the chat's gonna lose their mind if i
don't bring this to your attention you
you gotta
google on go to google right now and
type ethan klein net worth and see what
pops up
really everybody's losing their mind
about it
ethan klein net worth
oh it's a picture of david right yeah
you know it's been like this for a while
and i don't know why
this was like even before i started
caring about i have no idea
why it's just like what i don't know why
no clue this it's been like this for a
long time
here let me see it's all it's because
he's like a suggested thing
honestly they don't have a picture of me
what the [ __ ] are you going to write an
article with me and have pulled up like
david dover
let's see what dave is worth 20 million
he's got to be worth more than us yeah
that puzzle money is insane bro
i don't have puzzle money
such a goofy
everything else is used just the first
result online persona is like
most people have a wikipedia page right
who are like bubble figures but if you
type ethan klein
it doesn't pull anything because it's
like the first picture is james charles
because our wikipedia page is h3h3
production
i individually don't have my own page so
it doesn't
it always gets [ __ ] up on the on the
image because i don't have my own page
right
all right yeah it's david those are
right
right so um there's a lot of other
impersonators on tiktok it's all very
interesting
market for example here's a brazilian
vin diesel this is my favorite i [ __ ]
love this game how i feel about vin
diesel
[Music]
vin diesel brazil
yeah this guy's killing it for real
oh this one crashed into the beautiful
world
it's so good
does he talk like him let me get some
sound
[Applause]
yeah that's all that kind of crap
i love you guys getting a lot of views
i think it's also his full-time job it's
crazy
crazy dude
in the beautiful world when you're up
when your sweet ass came on
then you've got oh speaking of in diesel
we have a new camera angle from
beautiful world moment
which is kind of i mean it's just
interesting to see it from a new
yeah exactly where did that come from i
don't know i just i found it on tick
tock on my
for you page
[Music]
he's not just watching the same video
that we no it's a different angle no
this is a totally different
[Music]
[Music]
pretty interesting eh so then there's a
johnny so beautiful i'm in love
there's a johnny depp look-alike on tick
tock
this one is so cringe i can't [ __ ]
he's got 1.1 million followers so you're
just hating obviously
yeah i am yeah yeah yeah thank you
this guy doesn't look like johnny depp
sorry well his entire personality is
looking like him so well i guess with
makeup kind of
it's a [ __ ] barely there's like a
fleeting
resemblance yeah like i'm just not
buying it dude
sounds like you're the hater i am hating
on this one
yeah we don't like him folks
um oh he johnny dip as jared leto joker
what the f does that mean
you looked at it already oh that's come
on
uh somebody in the chat keeps uh saying
something about a
um a fake bruce willis on tick tock
that's pretty impressive because you
guys
are uh here's a fake news to read
instagram
oh my god oh my god
that looks like that's really good that
looks real
you can tell his face is just a little
long or some [ __ ]
but this looks like the real this is not
the real one
performance cruiser sport really
amazing all of them amazing motorcycles
is this real effect
well the page is fake right gq
he just posted a clip of of the real one
i love it man i love lookalikes it's
just so i wanna i just wanna
such a walmart keanu i would love to
make a podcast with all these
look-alikes
yeah it's like hosted by well you should
do it for trisha because she always
wants all these famous people on the
show
just start bringing fake ones it gets a
little weird when they don't actually
want to talk about anything
they just want it like what they just
start rep they just keep referencing and
[ __ ] it's like so how was it on the set
of matrix
one sentence from the movie well it'll
blow it's just like okay it'll blow your
mind if i had to tell you
speaking of the matrix please be can
uncanny
please be uncanny keanu please be okay
maybe what
we need to do is um
maybe you just need to plan a segment
that's just unrelated at all to the
character
they're just participating it as the
famous person oh wow this guy's crazy
yeah eb found the fake bruce willis you
should see this he's not on video
though it's just pictures but he's
pretty cool
his name is double broods awesome what
that
that avatar looks crazy whoa
so this one looks like an israeli dad
doesn't look like bruce this one looks
like a bruise but he's working those
shadows yeah those angles he looks more
like michael chiklis than bruce willis
oh don't do him like dirty like that
i think ilo's idea was good or maybe
have them act in a role that they didn't
play actually like keanu reeves playing
the terminator or something like that i
don't know
right i think you would just have to
have i think like the way tim and eric
use look alex is the best where they
just do like a cameo
and you don't explain that they're fakes
um we've got even a deep fake putin
which i think probably this guy
might already be dead yeah you know
he's got a lot of followers too check
out deep fake putin see this
this kind of stuff you see a lot of
nowadays and it's just like
it's just so stupid vladimir putin yeah
this is a this is a
i think this is you get murdered if you
do this in russia
legit jesus
this is about the quality that you
expect from defense that's why the tom
cruise one is so
impressive the thing about the the deep
cruise is that like
he perfected the hair the mannerisms
everything so it just comes out really
good right
it's also pretty funny like the magic
the content itself is yeah
yeah vladimir putin
so shout out to this guy's family since
he's passed away
vladimir putin steven seagal
vladimir putin
so dude we have a lot of great content
here
left we've got a lot of great show yeah
we have
for example you guys ready for a deep
dive
on an iconic after dark deep dive all
right
what do we got ready to get weird
soakers
suit soakers
these are let me guess it's a fetish
obviously of course
um is it on youtube yes it's all on
youtube
interesting is it like
some nowhere in russia no they're
americans
they seem to be americans from what i
can tell
okay do you think so i i i actually
thought that they were russian
russian i'm could be wrong
well all right so it's a fetish where
they
dress up in fancy suits and they either
pee themselves
or they blast water it's sexual and
that's what a fetish is
and um some of it i can't show you so
i'll just describe it but like it's all
about the bulge in the suit
and about the wetness of the suit and
about peeing in your own suit
and it's all on youtube folks i got a
piece so bad
oh germany of course it's in germany
those people are so depressed oh it's
just
german with peace and love to our german
fans like y'all are known for some weird
ass porn
really yes [ __ ] porn is like german
jaisa films i didn't know that chase the
filmer
[Music]
[Laughter]
so let's take a let's take a deep dive
into the suit
soakers
okay i'm going to warm you up now this
is part of the what we learned
previously is the wham
fetish which is the um wet and messy
wet and messy that was the one that you
were really disturbed by with the pie
and the hair and all that i hate that so
it's in the same
it's in the same realm of the wet and
messy fetish wet ass
p word right
so let's start light we're gonna we're
gonna the setting is the shower
and we're gonna be spraying ourselves
down with a light
misting of water we have some two girls
one cup type of music as well
i'll just give you a taste because i
don't know if i'm gonna get acclaimed
bored to soak a suit i don't know what
that means god i wish i could listen to
music it's so good
listen yeah
you think that well it doesn't sound
like claimable music no yeah
it's such two girl one cup music isn't
it yeah
i don't remember in that video oh you
weren't focused on the soundtrack
well the song is really famous so he's
got i've never seen a [ __ ] bob i
don't know what the [ __ ] that bottle is
you know like what is that it's like
some old timey
oh oh no oh why is he getting his suit
all wet like that
[Music]
squirting him
hey shredder they love it though man
these are a lot of
oh yeah some one of their videos has
like a million but it's too graphic to
show
but their channel name is called um suit
busters actually
music's a little loud so
i the music is kind of annoying with
muted that's so interesting
just spraying water well it gets it gets
more you know intense
this is just the entry-level stuff
because i kind of want to just
ease you in a little bit so
it's a little bit of like power play you
know the one getting soaked
show the nips get the nips wet a little
bit you know what it is
[Music]
oh whoa
sharp little yoko soundbot um
it's just i mean it's very odd right i
mean i don't know what
like why the suit right
i guess this i don't know
i just couldn't tell you but let's take
another look at those nips
right does that fit you now that it's
all wet [ __ ]
uh oh showing his ass
[Music]
you know he's he's he's posing he's
coming for a squirt oh oh
okay all right hey settle down there now
boy
a little too grabby with the hand no
he's getting them wet
[Laughter]
they're little they're kind of old too
the two guys are kind of like
middle age like late middle age you know
so they have had the time in life to
know what they like wait now they switch
yeah they're going to bust each other
so it's not necessarily a power thing
that's
what's so confusing about this one to me
is a lot with a lot of these fetishes
even if you're not into it you can kind
of wrap your head around where
the fetish lies this one just baffles me
like well the wet and messy in general
baffles me
yeah yeah see you see he grabbed for it
no no
[ __ ] keep your hands to yourself what'd
it be i
i have an idea that has something to do
with like sort of like an ocd of being
clean
and then just messing that all up
anybody
listening is into the wet and messy i'd
love to pick their brain
to understand it just on a basic level
you know
but yeah it's something it's something
of the taboo of like
maybe you maybe you grew up with a
really ocd mom clean your [ __ ]
bedroom
fold your socks the only crumbs on the
counter was like yeah mom well i'm gonna
grow up and wet my [ __ ] suit
you can't do anything about it it's like
an act of rebellion maybe
i mean i grew up with a mom like that
yeah well you also like getting pied in
the face you didn't
tell the audience that
love me daddy
oh you guys wanna maybe it's like for
people who work in a
suit environment office
these guys don't work in suit
environment i can tell you one thing for
sure
but there's a nice suits these are nice
suits
and suits are not oh okay all right we
don't like come on
we're on youtube but like suits are not
meant to get wet so
this is a fine italian suits oh
yeah there's like a there's a there's a
power thing here without getting messy
take your time [ __ ]
yeah so
pretty interesting stuff let's see the
comments i always like to see the
comments
let's see here from h3 what oh
come on guys i'm trying to get some real
comments this is
this is not cool guys okay i'm looking
at the old ones now two moth
uh when did this turn into beautiful
world that's us
i played with my boss once said
okay i really want to see your smart
leather shoes and sexy socks get a good
soaking so it's something about the nice
items being
uh-huh you're like ruining it very sexy
love the way you played with your
package you appear to be a commando guy
baby good observation
[Laughter]
someone's paying attention do underwear
breath hold with a suit underwater
breath hold with the suit
see these people have like these really
specific fantasies
he wants him to get in a pool and hold
his breath in a suit
and he's controlling someone saved me i
feel like they have some kind of like
uh with piss and love someone said it
has to do
wait when was that that's from two
minutes ago oh okay
[Laughter]
that's funny at least that one's funny
but it's like this is like national
geographic guys you guys can't
you can't disturb the natives yeah we
have a non we need to have a
non-intervention club
it's the it's like star trek yeah
non-interventional
they have this idea of like a ceo in a
suit
and then you like make them dirty and
right you're debasing them yeah because
that's part of the thing with the
with the girls with their hair they're
like pretty and have nice hair then they
get all
schmutzed up
someone says i would like you to do the
same in my suit
mucho hot bravo bravo
okay uh weird ended up on the dirty side
of youtube right you gotta do a lot of
click and end up on this video
so that's the firs that's our entry
level stuff here
what is going on with this one can i
click this one in no
i think it's just chocolate i'm just
gonna stick to the road map we have
yeah some of these were the next one we
have is
the countryside
wait that's the one that he actually
peeses yeah that's the pissing one
so i'll just show it to you and describe
it to you because i don't know if i can
show someone peeing their pants
necessarily
but he he's getting out of a car he he
can't find it here i'll show you guys
you can't find a bathroom
you just cut away then when he starts
studying by the way i do not get
american vibes here
yeah you're right this is in america
this is not america okay so he's like he
can't find a place to pee
he's in a really nice suit okay okay so
now he just pees in his suit
yeah he's peeing himself and you can
tell he's not wearing underwear either
he's in my basement and he might be
torqued too from what i can tell
a little bit at least he's just soaking
his suit man just like they say they do
i just peed in my basement it's just a
lot of peeing
while he's wearing his pants that's a
lot of pee
yeah i mean he probably prepared you
know
just in the middle of this whole country
room has half a million views
almost six hundred thousand actually
what comments are off for this one
that's a name
crazy so there you have that one
and now there's overlap with
oh oh we got age restricted why uh this
one you get a little overlap
with the wet and dirty i think there's a
pie involved at a certain point
someone probably got age restricted
because there's some package grappling
at some point
which will do our best to avoid the
package grab
you don't like you're not into this one
that's what i didn't like about the pie
one it's like too
um it's kind of aggressive
a few quick pies yola this one's more
playful maybe
[Music]
i want to smell feet yeah that's more
your fetish right you want to get some
feet on the screen
no so he's getting pied in his suit
right yeah yeah it is pretty aggressive
classic paper plate
it's the best way to buy something you
know just let's go
you can taste not even really pie it's
just a paper plate with like it's just
cream
it's just gonna make a mess i mean dan
these guys don't have time to cook pies
i'm just a little let down i wanna i'm i
signed up for pieing and this is just
creamy i mean a few quick pies they just
do this together real fast
it's called a few questions i thought
that was just your commentary
it's called a few quick pies and true to
their
name just a few quick buys real quick
this one was not a hit it only has four
thousand views
how did you find that it's on their
channel yeah
i actually found it i guess i just
forgot that this guy's pie iron man look
at this he's got this i can't believe
that the peeing one has half a million
or like more than that in views
well that's pretty hot so weird no that
one's pretty hot
like to actually see someone pee their
pants on youtube of all places
and it's not age restricted or anything
so that's pretty hot
don't be such a prude either
okay but here's their most popular video
with 800 000 views
okay almost a million this one so the
here's our homies in their suits
looking like a snack and a half it's
looking like a whole food all these
dudes look like
the bad guys in a jason statham movie
or just like the henchman extras yeah
exactly yeah
yeah but did you guys see how hot he
looked right
so here's the homies
looking pretty slick kind of it's kind
of funny how all of these videos could
pass as performance art
um interesting you got the classical
music guy commentary on
just the suit show so basically this one
is like
it's all about the bulge i think on this
one
so it's all because they don't even get
wet yeah it's just bulge action
i'm gonna get wet okay let's read the
comments and see
i have to say the bull junior suit
trousers is quite beautiful thank you
for letting us see it
two handsome men and great-looking suits
i mean cool i guess this one's from
eight years ago so this is a relic of
youtube
i really enjoyed watching this video
every second of it i like the suits the
way they were modeled
you guys look great i like that you
enjoyed wearing them and what might
happen to them
i like the shoe in the crotch there's a
moment where he put a shoe on his crotch
and seeing the crotch inside the suit
material thanks for doing this video
genuine appreciation for the work they
create
i love i had a beating comments here um
i could never look at men in a suit the
same again
wow changed their whole life we changed
you bro
and then this podcast no longer suits me
there you go hey now what would be hard
because if two i had to be
grinded together in your suits oh i love
the comment why are we watching this
question
why are we why anything this is after
dark this is the whole
point this is like the eternal struggle
people go
this is why we created after dark right
this is it
so people say some people say oh move on
it's like
well move on to what yeah that's what
we're here for move on to what
this is why we're here great show and
the meat
imprints are delicious
meat imprints ladies and gentlemen
wait what that's what he said meet
imprints right here
on the meat show no more calling it
bulge it's a meat imprint from now on
you like my meat
imprint nice here's a nice a really good
comment let's see
nice assortment of suits glad to see you
got a new pair of shoes he's washing
clothes
the pair you have been wearing were
getting a little tough looking
oh the hard-on was a nice touch
i'd say something is about to bust
i love feet 35 seconds ago
what's it called in star trek why am i
blanking they're like yeah it's the main
directive or the
prime directive the prime directive
there you go you guys are violating the
prime directive here
so there you have it you know
[Music]
busters ladies and gentlemen i like this
deep dive oh
that was interesting i mean it was
interesting and not quite as bad as like
it's not as disturbing
disturbing yeah not really um harmful
to anything almost just more fun a
couple dudes and a couple suits they're
just into suits they're just dudes
there was one scene where i didn't watch
but i think it's this one where you can
see the bulge
and he like flicks his dick i was like
that's pretty hot
just bros and suits man having a good
time that's hot
[Laughter]
nice yo people are tanking tom cruise on
wikifeed that's not cool he didn't
deserve that
tom wait what that's what eb said
unfortunately that's not cool i mean why
the foot soldiers sometimes go wrong get
a little zealous
get a little ronin on me they're gone
ronin yeah
you guys we got more weird [ __ ] i mean
here's a tick tock
of a guy who only eats raw meat i hate
it
i can't watch this raw meat are a
different breed of psychotic
and they're always like super um
they're always like super aggressive
like i've seen this guy go to like a
vegan protest and then he'll just like
bust out a raw liver and start eating
it's like why do you have to make it
about pissing people off
just eat your [ __ ] meat and die
eventually of a
s of a parasitic some sort
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here wait what's with all the virus
videos sorry you can use your
imagination
i'm sure here let's see oh this i know
this guy this is the original
anything that the tv tells them and they
don't realize that youtube is the new tv
david shut up okay i know this guy he's
such a [ __ ] lunatic
so here we go testicles brains
muscles belly fat liver spleen
and thymus whatever the [ __ ] that is
diamonds
blood so i i just ate the first testicle
i was too excited this is the second one
okay
do you hear yourself he said if you ever
say if you ever state
make that statement you should check
yourself in he says i just ate the first
testicle i was too excited
wait and this guy has a lot of followers
20 000 but this this one has a lot of
views i think just because it's
disturbing
this one had i'll double check this one
has 150
000 views no
so let's just do it all from a
family-owned farm
and healthy animals that's i mean i like
to hear that
i do like that i would eat the [ __ ] out
of that so i just
ate the first time i was too excited
this is the second one
oh what's that snap
i cannot yeah imagining anything worse
than this
stop bro what are you doing why are you
doing this
i mean like he's not doing anything
wrong right he's just eating some raw
meat
i mean right he looks like he's
regretting it though
that's right chubby right wake up
i mean should we really be disgusted
you're kidding me he's trying to give
him the benefit of the doubt he's saying
i've ever seen
oh that's it just to me i can't even
touch
raw stuff i mean the guy's got a point
right we're out there slaughtering the
animal you might as well get up close
and personal and see
what the the you know let's see
i'm just going to continue eating
no this is not okay
[Music]
bro is that a liver or a spleen or what
i feel like something's gotta be wrong
with this oh yes that
that is not and these people are
severely mentally ill
so there's like the jordan peterson all
meat diet is he drinking and then these
[ __ ] take it one
step why did the drink they say we're
not even gonna cook it you wanna look at
that drink again
you want to watch this again to see what
he drank do you know because he made it
sound like
let's see what he's eating
we're losing viewers that's what it's
all about though unfortunately
no what is that what is that you know
that it's all
nice oh it is like i think that he
prepared oh no
i thought it was just normal beverage
not with this guy
you curious about the viruses i'm scared
yeah let's go to part one let's just get
an idea where's part one what must be
this it's probably him
denying and [ __ ] right guys requested
another video you guys love
what i'm doing obviously absolutely i'm
not watching this
no okay we're done wait where's virus
part one
i spent three years solely looking into
the nature of viruses bacteria
protozoans fungus and parasites as a
practitioner i treated myself
and a number of other people
successfully long term for conditions of
the same and when i did my last iq and
aptitude test i was taken into a
separate room
and i was interrogated to see if i
cheated and more than anything unlike
google and facebook i don't have vested
financial interest dictating what i can
say
and i don't know shares in vaccine
companies so what is the virus anyway
well the virus is nothing this guy's
going to teach this guy's gotta
re-teach me forget everything you knew
about what a virus is
listen to me in the bathroom
[Music]
he was making it sound like his iq went
up or something from eating raw meat
it could be that like the brain
parasites he got are extra
like cpu chips or ram chips or something
to help him process faster
some people in the comments were saying
that uh that drink was just uh
kombucha that was the bottle but no but
i don't think
it comes in something that looks white i
think he was right i think you did that
i don't think so semen is
oh my god i forgot about the semen guy
then i had to skip it because i didn't
want to leave tom cruise waiting but
yo we got the semen guy so
um last week we had a lot of fun
watching this preacher we're watching
crazy christian preachers on tick tock
and this guy who's obsessed with semen
to the point where his own supporters
were like i'm going to stop
tithing to you if you don't stop talking
about siemen
and he said i refuse i will talk about
siemens right it's this is very
important to me
actually can you send that uh original
video just to re
just to um refresh sure apparently this
guy is somewhat infamous as he's done
lots of
interviews you have advocacy about semen
being the new milk and he did an
extended interview
with the young turks on on this specific
topic i'm i'm
actually surprised they landed this
exclusive interview
you know
uh such prestigious uh you know guests
how did how the hell did they get them
to your favorite so this was the video
just to refresh the strange thing that
milk comes from the mammary glands and
then et cetera et cetera
and i said that semen because you know
and this thing going back a year ago
with me talking about semen
and and then and starbucks lattes and
they do put it in there
many people slam me and
there's another kind of milk if
something
is produced it's another type of
testicle glands of a man
people tend to like milk that's produced
by the mammary glands of a
has woman out that people tend to like
semen that's produced by the testicle
glands of a man
testicle glands this guy is just really
trying so hard to
justify his consumption of cement
you know so um apparently
yeah so there's an update apparently
this one's even more interesting than
the original so let's go ahead and watch
without further ado
located for stoning gay people to death
how does that make you different
from someone yeah so apparently he's
like hates gay people but loves seaman
oh what
yeah yeah of course virulent try to
figure that out
no extremists that we cover in the news
on a regular basis
does that make you a so-called man of
god to want to stone people to death
no what it does it says about what it
does is i can
harvest the semen
and use it in my coffee it's got the
best voice
word of god i'm not the one that wrote
the script adam
listen moses said that it should be
you've got to drink seeds in the book of
legend
leviticus rather i'm not the director
ah so does he drink his own semen or
is it kosher to drink your own milk you
know well he's gonna get into that in a
moment oh he does oh
if you wanna you know be upset with
somebody be upset with moses
do you agree with the taliban and isis
uh
when they stone uh people to death uh
for things that are in their scripture
including uh being gay
well i have to tell you this that if if
the word of god
says stone uh based on
a heinous violation of humanity
uh and isis or al qaeda or anybody
else who has the wisdom
and the integrity uh
understanding that yes about moses then
yes i agree with them yeah
you think that being gay is a lifestyle
choice right which it absolutely is not
i mean i would be very amused if you
could tell me
the specific moment in your life such a
dumb interview though it's like okay
yeah we all we know he hates gay people
get to the semen
it's like i've heard this conversation a
million times
it's coming up in a second here okay
good it's like they really
i just listen they really think they're
doing something with these gay questions
talk about semen which didn't happen you
were just born that way correct stone
the gays blah blah blah
blah blah being gay is a lifestyle
choice do you think that it's something
that
tempts people is it something that's
tempted you maybe
ah the best witness to answer your
question
and you can then follow up with an
interview with her is charlene mcrae
who is the wife of bill humpty dumpty de
blasio here in new york city
who says before making the mother she
was a lesbo
and then after marrying him she decided
to go back
straight so it's a choice it's a choice
and she bought children but she said
prior to that that she you know she ran
around with the rest of the sodomites
so you know you'll have to ask yeah
you said that was putting semen of the
no i think he needs to find out about it
some dick flipping yeah
i am not gay you might be gay you
definitely
you might be gay most likely might be
gay
what does it mean if you put semen in
your milk
and i got news for you that means you're
gay
iced tea thinks that makes him gay you
might be right b
but here's the interesting part because
it quote it flavors
up the coffee and it makes you think
you're having a good time
which that makes me wonder do you equate
drinking semen with a good time
well you know you're pushing me up in a
little bit of a corner here now jake
because i have to be very cautious here
but let me in my and and all precautions
that i can
exercise and now say that
you know a number of people think that
semen tastes good bro i can't do this
how is this real oh my god i can't do
this
this guy literally went from stone and
gays to semen tastes good
oh some people say that semen
tastes good why would you even put that
out there just enjoy the semen in your
own
time bro if you're going to try to
preach stone and gay people you can't
tell me that sema tastes good
semen is is another kind of milk
a number of people think that drinking
semen is a good idea
and you did i can't you did
you're sound biting all this right zach
a number oh yeah
a number of people think see drinking
semen is a good idea
i love it it's not just tastes good it's
a good idea
people have thought about this
extensively
you can get it at starbucks oh my god
man this guy is something else this guy
has like
probably this guy's probably got gallons
of semen in his fridge that he collects
from people on craigslist and [ __ ]
yeah after he stones them apparently
yeah he's like you disgust me
no can i get that semen please for my
coffee
it's not that way no ad i don't think
that myself
disgusting but i'm just giving you the
references of what other people
and that's just the way you've described
it in uh your past sermons but okay
continue
so okay so if a number of people i mean
you've got literally
millions of people around the world who
really
think that you know the taste of of
semen
is quite uh in uh a a flavor
and millions of people i don't
understand the argument there's lots of
people that think having
you know anal sex is a great idea so so
what's wrong with that thought but
liking semen is okay
it's odd they seek it in the midst of
other kinds of
activities and so one would think
well all right we'll start with one not
one thing starbucks has deduced
that listen you know in an ingenious way
i would say that one more more
infamous and genius way they've
discovered that since people like semen
people like i think most people agree
siemens like does not
taste good right so many people drinking
it from one another
their body fluids why not put it in our
coffees
and flavor up our coffees
i'm getting a sense here overall this
this obsession with starbucks coffee
leave my coffee alone well he's
convinced that start he thinks starbucks
secretly puts semen in their coffee
okay like that's what that's like
there's some like semen farm
right and and the and the reason for his
theory is that semen tastes great and so
they're geniuses how would you know that
semen tastes great that's a great
question
question bro the same experience
with semen in the and their lattes as
they had
this guy pulls up to starbucks and he's
like extra semen please
no you're putting i know y'all quack
that extra semen one pump
one extra pump of semen please
from your descriptions here that you
think that being gay is a lifestyle
choice there's a choice a lot of people
would want to make
you think that semen is delicious to a
lot of people and these are choices
that people make so it seems like
perhaps if it wasn't for the bible and
the teachings of moses etc that
that you might have been tempted by
those choices as well
uh is that is that the case have you
been tempted
oh absolutely no no no no doubt about it
you know what
i just want to [ __ ] dudes this is such a
[ __ ]
this is what god does to your brain man
this poor guy just wants to [ __ ] dude
so bad that he's convinced himself
he would be loving this the spray suit
suit busters yeah i think i think half
those views were him
yeah he was all like i love this new
shoes
i love your meat uh what do they call it
your meat silo prince
yeah i love their meat imprint
this poor guy dude look how [ __ ] up he
is just because like you forget about
moses
just go suck dick don't be free make you
so happy to suck dick
go be free and imagine what a good gay
he would be
not only does he he loves the taste of
seaman
like you would be one of the best gays
ever people would love being around you
he just loves the taste of semen that's
everyone's dream to absolutely
love demons this guy would be the best
gay in town
my god i mean even his backdrop looks
kind of like a
rest stop vibe
[Laughter]
i would not date a man and she would
[Music]
and uh i tell you that i saw a lot of
that activity going on
in in prison i mean it was it was just
the order there was a problem for the
course i was in one prince i was in
down in um in rayford florida
called union correctional facility uh
where the average sentence back in the
19 late 70s when i was there in that
prison the average sentence jinx this is
no lie
was a hundred years i mean judges
throughout 100 years sentenced to
prisons prison sentences and told people
like it was okay like it was a semen in
a latte
giving away that is sad though what are
you saying and they
form unions the first same-sex marriage
i saw was a marriage of
a sodomite named bahamas mama who had
dyed his hair red
used to walk around the white shorts
tight as you could possibly be in a hall
to top
and one side remember he was looking
good he was looking so good remember
very clearly what he was wearing boy
he was looking real nice in that halter
top and tight white jeans
do you think he would come talk to us on
that's what i was wearing why did they
get this exclusive yeah
i want to talk to the milk guys
can we try to reach out to himself he
seems to be pretty open to uh
i want to get the milkman on okay
what is the time the date stamp is that
2018
this one is from 2015 so oh it was a
while ago
oh wow maybe oh maybe it's a lot's
changed in the last six years you know
maybe
no no no no nothing's changed or the
milk man
this perch is still classified as a hate
group he once said obama's the next
hitler
his church was classified as a hate
group you said yeah by different
organizations in harlem yeah
it's just so ironic that a hate group
could love semen so much
yeah well we hate everything everybody
but we look like
many people millions of people love
sleep
everybody knows semen is is another kind
of milk
it's not at all another kind of milk
it's literally has not
at all milk milk is milk
it's meant to be consumed semen
on the yard you know they had a marriage
he got married to one of the inmates and
all the other inmates were
broken-hearted because they could no
longer
pursue sex with him so yeah i saw that
and
was tempted but i didn't yield to
temptation by the way you need to know
that peace and love
you need to know that you need to know
that oh
boy that guy's a character man
it just sucks that he has to be so
hateful and bigoted
but moses and some you think moses cares
if you want to suck dick
i'll call moses right now i got his
number i'm sure he doesn't care
[Laughter]
i just think it's such a shame that you
know it's so messed up that this guy
just wants to suck this
is kind of like the root of all problems
yes i mean that's what we just heard
like he is tempted
he would have like to be gay yes and
instead he's gotta go and talk about
stoning gay people what now
if you stone a gay person
you can't drain the nut sack of all the
available semen before
burial in fact we used to do that in
prison
at some one time i thought he was dead
but he was actually alive and i started
harvesting his semen with my mouth
and then he said he was still awake
and i finished him off because i was
already committed
and that's how i got semen that day i
was just looking to get some milk
for the cafeteria one time i go
into the cafeteria and i mistook the
bottle of milk for a man's penis
and i said well i'm already here so
let's use the seaming
seam
dude in the last video there was
literally people saying
if you don't stop talking about semen
i'm going to leave the church
and he's like no this is everything to
me he didn't just say no he said
leave you could not believe because this
is the church of semen christ
there's another kind of milk
just curious how he would mix the semen
i don't see it mixing well
wait what would the coffee think if he
thinks it's hidden in the coffee yeah i
don't think
i loot it well um they have some kind of
pro uh
they process it yeah pasteurized
moisturizer
you know
like you don't drink raw milk they
process that [ __ ] they pasteurize you
know
they sometimes they skim the fat out
all right well this is starbucks i mean
they have well they have health codes to
live up to
like they're not just putting raw semen
yeah and like
he if you're if you're sim inseminating
that much coffee
you have like a huge semen farm
usually you have a lot of similar
process so they're probably boiling it
skimming off the top can you imagine the
smell in that factory oh my god
it smells good in here
reminds me of prison
wow oh is this a statement on his church
zach what is this
yeah it's the first thing that popped up
i don't know he opened his website
dude you could be best friends with
these people it's like why has it got to
be like this you know
he's called the atla church
yeah yeah like atlanta or something wait
they always welcome lgbt members
well as long as they don't they come and
sin no more i see so yeah they gotta
drop the gay
act
they gotta do what he's doing he said we
might have believed in love after the
word of jesus he lovingly forgave
a woman caught in adultery about to be
stoned
what a guy we realized many find the
bible antiquated and out of step with
modern times
however we humbly ask that all would
respect our first amendment rights to
cling
really cling cling to the only faith and
hope we know
the claim doesn't sound good it's like
when you're like no
i know it's messed it's a weird word
we have honored and accepted many who
have been lgbtq as church leaders and
have named our church
courtyard after deacon williams a loving
member who was passed from among us
so they deny it they're with it
we have semen drinking rituals
[Music]
they have whole sermons about semen at
this church
apparently many many churches drink the
blood of jesus we blink drink the same
men of jesus
[Music]
that's the blood of god and we love
because it tastes good and it's just a
different type of milk
oh apparently they're doing they're
doing some kind of tax fraud as well i
didn't even know they had to pay taxes
the church owed over 1 million in bills
and back taxes according to creditors
nice a homeless shelter for lgbtq that's
another kind of
milk i love him he's my favorite let's
get him on the show please
all right i'm going to reach out james
manning well that's about it
you know it's about the show
how long we've been going here uh we
have been live for two hours seven
minutes
you know i do want to say because people
keep bringing up this i'm going to talk
about david dobrik
but it's not in the way you think and
i've put it at the back because
i know that there's a lot of people that
don't want to hear them on it they don't
want to hear about it
well it's over you can leave if you want
yo what do you want to eat tonight
because like we're we're close to the
end you want mex
you we should go for a drive okay
and drink some sea man you want drinks
tonight
there's another kind of love of coffee
if that's where you're i'll choose in
your coffee
just like starbucks that's why
starbuck's so good that's what he's
saying starbucks has just got this
flavor you can't get anywhere else
little calm shot
ew what so
did so people been bringing this up a
lot he's got this app
dyspo and there's this whole story about
did he steal the name from this guy
now we looked extensively into this and
we were convinced after
a lot of looking that david did steal
the name of this app
um because he's in this one paparazzi
thing
here let me see well hold on dan
let me tell my story
well at first we came to the conclusion
that he did steal it
um because so you're just this video
here this paparazzi video here
oh your startup raised four million
dollars yeah
that's amazing that's amazing but
there's there's speculations that you
like stole
someone's idea and like people are like
yeah i saw that what's going on with
that
i here's the thing yeah i really don't
like talking about this stuff because
there's so many rumors that are you know
i go around on the internet and i don't
have time to address them all but since
you're here
yeah i'll give you the inside scoop okay
um we registered that name
in um dyspo we registered that name in
june yeah
um you can google that that's like
public information okay and then
so we did we googled it and the only
thing we found
this guy recommended dyspo on like i'm
just
on like september 4th i'm just i don't
know the exact days but like four days
later
they made the dyspo account they made
this
all the social medias and then they
registered dyspo
a copyright for dyspo and we're like
dude
there all the evidence shows that you
stole the name from that guy for sure
okay so we were ready we were like man
this is crazy there's nothing out there
but then
suddenly we found something that totally
blew the part the story apart
which is um
which is this part here
which i'm not seeing here's the
here's the trademark oh it doesn't even
work
this link doesn't work don't even know
you were talking about that
where are you looking for these links
this link doesn't work
and then so so here you can see
oh here's the trip so where's the
evidence that he didn't do it because
it's not in here
also the links you guys put in here
doesn't work just says air
i i don't this is news to me that we're
even talking about that where are you
looking
literally the parts that did david steal
the name of his app dyspo
in what doc like the [ __ ] the same
doc we always use
listen to discord dan we put this whole
thing together
wake up anyway we found out
that he actually registered the name of
his website which is dyspo dot
fun which is kind of a fun
hell of a name and uh he had actually
registered the hosting for dyspo.fun
before the suggestion came through
so they bought the name dyspo
before the recommendation so what i
think happened is when he saw this other
guy say it
he was like oh [ __ ] i better get all
these social media
and register it because now the cat's
out of the bag a little bit
so i actually in the midst of all this
david controversy i do
have to acquit him on the charge of
stealing the dispo name from a fan
as uh listen we're here to be fair and
balanced
and we looked deeply into this
and ultimately as we dug we we have to
acquit david on the charge of stealing
dyspo
where's that document uh dan
[Music]
i i don't know i don't know how do you
not you don't see this no don't you ask
someone else
oh well dan's the one that was asking me
i don't know he was saying where is it
you don't see where it is though
in the after dark dark yes
whatever it doesn't really matter i mean
the
the story is that he didn't steal it
yeah he didn't steal it
so i see a lot of people trying to run
that and
trying to get me to talk about it so i'm
happy to acquit david
my arch nemesis i'm just kidding
all right david
oh people want us to talk about dirt day
[ __ ] it i don't care i'll watch it
they've been asking the whole time sure
i'll watch it i don't give a [ __ ]
dirty the thing i figured i would talk a
story the thing is i figured i would
talk about with trisha on monday so
but i'll talk it at the back and then if
you don't want to hear me repeat myself
then
don't watch it or watch it twice i don't
give a [ __ ]
we just sold another token what what
happened ian
uh we just sold another ian token
you know it's funny ian goes kazak
didn't sell a token last night
and we're worried that zach wasn't gonna
sell one he did
and we're like oh man it sucks because
everyone's getting paid
and then ian was like oh we'll share it
but now ian sold
three to everybody's one are you still
wanting to pool the money
i think you maybe misheard me i was like
wouldn't it be
funny if we shared it it would be funny
right yeah psych
dude i don't know how i misheard
something how does it feel to be so
beloved i mean look at you selling three
tokens look at you
yeah yeah i i still think the other
tokens will sell
i don't know people are jumping around
it's very random
yeah i'm bullying oh well you know ab
was the first
crew member to sell a token so we
thought oh
what an interesting development you know
and the popularity contest is kind of
going on amongst the crew
i mean dan dan's token is literally i'll
sell you a bridge but somebody bought
that so
but i actually went in i'm sorry when
ian suggested splitting it was just mine
and dan that sold
oh is that right yeah oh so you hadn't
even sold a token when you suggested
that's fine that is
i don't know how i misheard you saying
that ian when you you put it in writing
do you mean that i misread it did you
find it right because you because you
did put that in
writing go ahead and find what ian said
i think
you know glitch autocorrect oh
it's an autocorrect thing that makes
sense
wow well congratulations ian that's
three [ __ ] ethereum that is basically
the enough to power an entire
residential block for uh
10 years can you redeem that energy in
some way
i wonder that'd be cool if you could
like
you could be like yo here's a energy
token nigeria power your [ __ ]
here's some ac for a year no it'd be
cool if it worked like that but
unfortunately not
so this guy dirty dom like so i didn't
i didn't really prepare to talk about
this so forgive me if i'm ignorant in
some ways
i obviously watched it
maybe you know about these guys so tell
me the background about this guy
first of all uh dom so don was one of
the
like original characters in david's
videos oh this is related to david yeah
he put out a video basically saying that
what seth and nick are saying is true
and the way we used to behave when i was
with them was messed up and it's totally
wrong how we bully people and really
jonah which is the fat guy everyone
makes fun of they call him he's like his
name's nick he's not even named jonah we
just call him jonah because
we're making fun of him because he looks
like jonah hill which is crazy because i
didn't even know his name was nick
john is not even fat anymore right jonah
looks great
um oh sorry we have receipts t-channels
pay attention now
ian
we so we just need to sell zach we just
need zach to sell a coin i said so we're
all paid
oh so this so that sounds like it sounds
like ian was sold yeah it was yeah ian
was sold at the time he said they say
i apologize yeah what the [ __ ] i've seen
slander
bro you might have to you might have
formation here
no just because of this slander i we
shouldn't split it right now i'm not
splitting with this i agree with that
well also in my defense i said don't
worry zach if you don't sell i'll split
mine with you and i'll take you to
dinner i told them
no you said it was one or the other you
said i could explain it
okay yeah you said it was one or the
other but that was still a nice gesture
and i thought i was definitely going to
pick
but we don't even need to worry about
that because we're all on the board baby
yeah that's true numbers
why does he get more yeah cause people
like him better what if we want to split
it
you know also i i got another piece of
information
um another ian token just sold
wait for real are you seriously serious
that's
four ian tokens i don't believe him i've
got to go check ian are you buying it
yourself
did you just spend did you just use the
coin that you got to buy your own
coinbase
it's on the blockchain baby it's all
public so that's easy to verify oh
really but i gotta
look i don't even i don't believe it
ian's on the board with people like
he's got the same amount of coins as me
now i'm feeling
i'm not feeling feeling the pressure a
little bit i'm not like i'm just ready
to retire at this point
hold on let me find the oh you guys
didn't put the link can we get a link in
the chat like oh my god
how are people going to buy our coins if
they don't have our link oh my god you
guys
what are you talking about just use the
point that you got there's no link
in the in the youtube video oh in like
today's stream
yeah just trying to find could someone
send me the link i'm saying
navigate here let's see
all right proof is in the pudding here
fellas
this is exciting man we got activity
dude there's only one look at all this
ian activity
three coins wait you sold three coins
what today you mean no there's three
coin sales in the past nine minutes look
wait it's all by the same guy somebody
bought them all the same dudes buying
all your coins ian you got a super fan
out there he wants to [ __ ]
he wants to soak your suit bro wow
we just got a bid on the vape nation too
what's up yo someone wants to soak your
suit ian
one guy bought three of your tokens
wait that means there's no more ian
tokens are they also
wait is that accurate yeah i think
they're all owned by other people at
this point
look what three owners yeah
they're sold out you're right one dude
one guy bought one three three he's
banking this guy knows
zombler dude you better but shut up
zombies
[Applause]
[Music]
a big um moment money bags tell us what
are you gonna do with all the
coins are you gonna hold them are you
gonna sell them what are you gonna do
ian
i would say i'm going to disneyland but
i'm not i'm not going there
right well you know all this work i'm
going to get done i think i might you
know extend my chin
do a little facial work yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you know bleach my earlobes kind of
go out out more lube you want to get
some lube work
yeah some love work
work well i'll loop you up i'll lube
your suit up boy
i'll soak him a suit too i i gotta send
a soaked suit too
dude this is so crazy i cannot believe
that we're selling this
i cannot believe ian you sold all your
coins this is amazing
tokens tokens okay thank you what the
[ __ ]
dude shout out to zombies please call in
i want to talk to you man
yeah we'd love to we'd love to speak
with you the guy sees value i think i
think he sees value in the ian
so now wait what was that someone can
buy it from him oh so someone just sent
him an
offer oh that's just what i was gonna
ask so this guy
dude there's a lot of activity right now
this guy just sent an offer to that
homie the market's hot for one
we gotta run on the market people but he
wants to buy it at the original price
come on dog we gotta resell it
dude if he resells it for two tokens
right now i'm gonna freak out
[Laughter]
i cannot believe what's happening
[Laughter]
you know there's an option so that
anytime there's a resale you can take a
commission from it
right but i turned that off because like
that's not how this [ __ ] works you buy
it you own it
that actually well i mean but that's how
a lot of people are
are doing it we were just talking before
the show uh uh mf doom's family is
selling
some limited things for his memory or
whatever his nfts
it's like masks or something and yeah
they're doing it as the smart contract
so if people buy it
uh and then turn around and sell it
every time it's sold forever more
they'll get a small cut of this i mean
i that's an interesting feature cool
yeah i turned it off for us though
because i think
i'm not doing this as a money-making
scheme it's more just like what is this
[ __ ]
you know go make a billion dollars on it
i don't give a [ __ ]
i added it to the description if people
want to
check it out um ian
wow and now there's a whole there's a
whole aftermarket for you ian
no if i if we had commission on those
sales i'd be able to get a nice little
diamond in my face
yeah yeah you plant me right maybe it's
we can get your ass a cute that's our
giant zirconium for your forehead
that's cool congrats ian yeah thanks
guys i mean my original
my original idea was that you guys would
keep the your own individual token money
this notion of sharing yeah
that's i think that's a pretty good idea
it's interesting how it's all flipping
though
that was my original idea this whole
notion of sharing was just but it was
just
suggested by it was ian's idea it was
suggested by ian
you should keep your tokens no it's only
fair we keep our tokens
look everyone got paid joker brain
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god you guys we have two joker
brains on the map zach
how does it feel about now that people
know that money actually goes to the
guys they're more willing to buy it
because
i said that from the beginning i'm not
kidding you did not get money yeah oh
i don't think it was clear wow i mean i
said it in the yesterday when i pitched
it
these guys get all the money thank you
very much peenpoon
that's rolex money for zach
this peenproof is a shitload wait no
it's not almost though
he just messaged me on discord get him
up
get him on what a first guy doing with
his money man
i'm going to be better usage hold on i
got to connect you ethan
pinpoon was also involved in bidding
here oh he cancelled his bid what the
[ __ ] beanpoon well he decided to buy his
actions he bought it
oh he got outbid though yo i'm super
interested on the gold
coin i feel like i'm hacking your laptop
right now don't
go ahead i feel like this gold coin
might actually go for some real cheddar
cheese
i'm feeling 20 000 i'm feeling
i'm feeling 10 coins for that tokens
no coins i'm feeling 10 coins for that
token
okay you're in the uh he's ready if
you're able to
get the call set up sec um so this is
we're getting on the phone
peenpoon who's spot to or
yeah well he had bid previously and now
he bought one let's check his wallet so
you can check him and see what he owns
oh this guy owns a lot of crypto art yep
he owns a pullman right now this one he
bought
people own yeah publicly that's the
whole like
appeal well it's not the whole appeal
but a big part of the appeal of all of
this is it's
is it it's all out in the open it's all
transparent it's all public so
you you can always see when it's been
sold how much it's been sold for
this is his most precious art he bought
this for five thousand
more because there's a little bit of
like a show-offy thing
absolutely yeah that's that's cool
that's where a lot of people think the
the value is is the uh i didn't know
that
yeah would you like me to bring them in
right now yes please bring the peenpoon
in
bring in the poon
[Laughter]
so i'm a crypto artist and i've been on
a site called super rare for like a year
and basically it's been paying all of my
living expenses like this is the only
thing i do
wow so yeah i knew like i'm a huge fan
of the hd podcast so when i saw you guys
uh talking about nfts like yesterday on
the vip preview i was like oh
this is like this is it bro uh so yeah
i've been bidding on the
the one one vape nation nft because it's
the most valuable because it's one of
one
i saw that i saw you were involved in
that what do you think that one's
worth if you had to guess as the bidding
goes up there's a lot of time out but
what how much are you willing to spend
on that
bro i mean i only have like one eighth
1.5 youth to
to barter with but it's honestly going
to be
and like 10 8 should have definitely put
the uh you should have put the
uh royalties on it's like that's what
every crypto artist does is they they
earn royalties
but like it gets crazy you saw the
people sale for 70 million so we would
have
to remember from youtube no that means
that if someone resells it we get the
like
[Music]
but don't you think it makes it more
valuable that i don't have the royalty
on it
it makes it more valuable that it's one
of one that's like what all that's what
people care about
the royalties are like honestly a good
thing because people want artists to get
their revenue like well i'm not an
artist i'm just an [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
but i see what you mean i'm saying
though you know
well it's too late to turn it on so what
can i do
you create it's okay though yeah are you
an artist
yeah yeah i'm a 3d artist here let me
click your [ __ ] like
a little over a year and as you can see
i have like a bunch of
tokens on my openc profile but i'm on
super
air foundation like doing crypto art uh
doing 3d art that's kind of like
real it's just art like this you know
that they sell right
yeah like the branding for crypto for
cryptocurrency
connected to art like easy branding for
nfts
are any of these years that i'm looking
at in your wallet
yeah the ones that look like goddesses
uh with floating stuff or mostly mine
this one
you check out my super rare profile
actually i'll link that right now
this one is discord maybe you were
talking to zach and discord right
you can send it in there exactly send it
to zach and he'll pass it along to us
cool and yeah i was in here you know dan
i think you noticed my name a couple
days ago i was trying to
vouch for the nft side of things so
tell me why did you buy the
environmental side of things
why did you buy the zach one
because zach hadn't gotten any sales yet
so i mean it's definitely a thing to
like
buy people's first nft and i've done
that a couple of times in the past
um so yeah i saw zach hadn't got one so
i knew i had to get one and
you know i'm sure just so you know i'm
gonna put this up on social and i'm sure
zak's will sell out pretty soon too
so do you see value in it like it would
go up in
in uh over time or why
i think so buy it
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i think the value is going
to go up for sure and like obviously i'm
invested in the community having like
making
all my income from this so yeah but yeah
i mean i wouldn't be surprised if i
start getting like one point five or two
eighth bids so people will come
to youtube on all of them that's
interesting so people will come to you
they'll say oh he owns this that i want
and they'll just make an offer and you
can decide to accept it or not
um let me ask you exactly is someone
offered you two right now would you take
it
on a timed auction would you say if
someone offered you two right now would
you take it
uh it probably holds because that just
means there's interest in it so
just hold it tall yeah yeah
hold it until rainy days well well
thanks for supporting uh young sweet
zack we love that yeah i appreciate that
thank you man
of course so i want to i want to plug
your thing a little bit here uh peenpoon
is it just ping pong ping pong
love said there's nudity on that website
so i'm scared to hold it but it's peen
poon right so people just look up ping
pong
check out your heart yeah all right
there's no nudity on my specific profile
and i
sent that to zach i sent in the general
oh there you go
and you got it yeah the general
um so yeah that's like my current works
you can see that i have like some stuff
that recently sold
what's the most valuable for 4 500
so it's pretty cool you know 4500 really
crazy i mean
yeah you sold this one that's awesome
it says last 2.7 that's [ __ ] what's
up dude
nice good for you yeah i only have one
that's not sold yet and that's one
going for 2.7 druid oh i see
that's sick bro how do you create and i
started
on what on what song i use blender
uh which is like a 3d 3d renderer then i
also use like photoshop
uh octane render adobe after effects to
combine it all together and then i also
make my own music for
using ableton live yo how does that guy
beeple make one
of these every day well he is like the
super
legit uh uh what do you call it
partnership with turbo squid so he can
like download unlimited assets basically
and use them wherever he wants and he's
also just like really good you know he's
been doing this for like 15 years so
respect definitely well good luck dude
thanks for
participating it was fun and uh nice to
hear about just the people involved so
good luck god bless and lots of love to
hear us like
be so clueless about it or are you just
used to it like that's just
it so it's only frustrating like for
example ethan was like oh this is a scam
and this is bubble it's like obviously
everyone is entitled to their own
opinion but
like the artists that are down here were
like obviously invested in the space so
to hear people kind of poop on it is
hurtful
but mostly there's a lot of
misinformation going around
with uh like the environmental impacts
and stuff and like you're saying
nobody really knows about a uh the
energy tokens or things like that which
like
are totally a thing yeah mm-hmm
well listen well it seems
we're selling i love you what's
yeah digital artists this whole new
market right
exactly yeah just hop on twitter and
start tagging yourself with like
crypt hashtag cryptoer and you'll just
like you'll see a huge
emerge emergence of all of us out of the
woodwork oh what am i supposed to do go
on twitter and tag
crypto that's it it's the hashtag
cryptoart hashtag nft
honestly and then you'll just see people
like start fighting to get you on
what do you mean basically that is good
advice that is good advice
okay yeah dude yeah write that down dan
i've been in this guy
hashtag crypto nfd all right yeah that's
it
thank you thanks for chatting with us
appreciate it
i want to check out the walter the guy
who bought three ian's
that's all he owns only owns three ian's
he's a dude
how is this not you ann well be honest
specifically he only owns
it on this platform because there are
multiple places where people do this and
so you're only
you know this guy might be really into
this but doesn't normally shop on openc
and so this is the first time am i going
to get charged back
no chargeback doesn't work that's not
how it works it doesn't work all right
let's talk about this guy
so dom is
who is he a b was about to explain what
he was easy
yeah he was uh david's roommate uh when
they first got a place together
in california and he was heavily in a
lot of his uh first videos so
he's like he's well known by david fans
now the thing about
dom is that isn't he accused of like
some heinous
[ __ ] i believe he's accused of sexual
assault at vidcon
so like it's just i found it i i don't
know the
the veracity of those claims are those
i know he put out a video being like i'm
sorry about what happened at vidcon but
i don't know what he's accused of
he put out viewing like i'm so sorry
about what happened at vidcon and then
in the comments is david dobrik being
like you
it's okay dude we forgive you mistakes
happen or some [ __ ] like that
so i don't know what he's accused of or
what is this guy some kind of predator
what's the deal with
with dom i'm not sure i
wasn't following up with that saga too
much but i don't think any legal action
was taken at the time
amy you took a picture with him yeah i
did thank you for letting everyone know
did you write him down what's the deal
with that
uh no so last time me and lena were in
california actually
i was uh at the mall on in west
hollywood
and some guy was like uh hey i'm sorry i
wasn't staring at you i think i have
those same pants and
it was dumb and i was like oh what's up
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
you're telling me dom approached you
because you liked your pants
i swear to god because he was like
staring down and he was like oh sorry
dude i think i have those same pants
he was really nice when i met him
he's not like
zach you as abe's friend do you believe
this story
oh [ __ ]
coming from zach bro what does that mean
i think i don't i mean his stories are
all true for sure
when is what is zach lied about wait
what didn't tell him
i no i think he's telling the truth yeah
i don't think he's lying okay there you
go there it is yeah yeah he backed out
real fast you must have some dirt on him
when have i ever lied abe yeah what is
he lied about amy go ahead
he's like scarface he always tells the
truth even when he lies right
is that true of zack do you tell him
[ __ ] you
i have no idea what you're talking about
interesting
i'm kidding no i don't i believe his
story yeah i completely believe this
story i mean
it happens you see these people walking
around they walk around they ask about
your pants
yeah get some semen milk from you
did you see his dick did you see his
meat imprint on his pants
he was looking at my pants i don't know
if he saw mine i don't know
so anyway this guy is old he was like i
guess david's childhood friend yadda
yadda
there's been a lot of stuff going on i
thought the video was kind of
i don't know he doesn't really say
anything he's just like yeah nick and
seth
and i believe them and he speaks kind of
cryptically where he like
i feel like he doesn't just come out and
say what he's trying to say
you know i just kind of wanted to clear
the air up about some things
and give my perspective and you know my
thoughts on
everything that's happening so i i moved
out here in 2015
with he says david i'm it's long i don't
know i don't feel like watching 15
minutes of this
um he says that david eventually just
drifted out and stopped asking him to be
in his videos and [ __ ]
and i had two girls move in
she's super dope bro it's it's not that
good i just didn't think it was that
good he didn't really say anything new
i don't know but i guess it's better
than is there something specific that
people wanted me to comment on i mean
realize that these certain jokes and
these yeah he said you're saying yeah we
were bullies we were
we were doing [ __ ] up that's good yeah
at least he's saying that yeah i agree
it's good it's great not like
what scotty did right totally
i feel like he's he's broken out of the
cult and so he can own
he can take accountability and he
doesn't have money in dyspo
and he doesn't as far as i am aware have
david tattooed on me either
you know
yeah i don't know anything about it but
i think at least just saying that is
better no i was in videos where i was
what we've seen so far kissing guys
right but
for me personally known for not
sticking up and for not saying no and
for not
uh putting my foot down seeing
he says he feels guilty and responsible
for the stuff they did back in the day
seth's situation and him coming out
about it
you know two years later three years
later
um it really hurts me because
i know i wasn't the best
at times either blah blah blah yeah
when it makes their brands look good and
when it brings them more money
yadda yadda yadda yadda he's talking
about seth accountability blah blah blah
i mean there's not i don't have anything
to add to it
i don't think i don't know if that's an
appropriate response to this video
people are looking for
you know yeah um
man ian is out of coins that's a [ __ ]
crazy dude
sick
that's it ian what are you doing
you've got so many ethereum bro you're
like smog from
the hobbit you got all these coins and
treasures around you
i know i think well it's time for me to
retire thank you guys
you'll keep it in this currency or
you'll
cash in i don't know
i mean dan thinks no right yeah dan
thinks that's kind of we should follow
that
i'm sorry to interrupt i have the person
that bought all of the tokens the ian
tokens
i'm talking to him too he said i'm ready
to buy all your tokens to
whose abs yeah oh we got quite a
collector here
bring him on which guy is this let me
open the activity
this is um zombies
zom oh yeah he only owns all he has is
ian
tokens zombies oh and he's got a bid on
on the gold as well he currently has top
bid on the goldies
no he doesn't he got outbid by luca
all right i'm bringing them on right now
i've got a bidding war over here bear on
on the car right now
all righty we've got the legend
zombiers zombies i am gramblers
that's me why did you buy so many why
did you buy three ian tokens
oh i was ready to buy all of them but
someone else bought the rest of them but
i bought three
because i think they're going way up in
value really you think the ians may be
the most valuable of all the tokens
we've commented
oh yeah if you see the artwork on that
one it's the greatest
it is my favorite one so it has nothing
to do with you
liking ian as a person it's more about
the artwork
oh i like ian he's always been the best
thing when he was an intern
right right he's always been a golden
one yeah he's a salaried employee
he's not the golden boy that's zach but
he's definitely a golden one
there's a reason we started paying him a
salary you know what i mean
he's great
so this is incredible so did you buy the
coins or did you have them in a wallet
like how do you how did you obtain the
ethereum
oh i have a lot of ethereum so i
i had plenty in my uh bank account can
you give me an idea of how many you have
i mean you're anonymous
i'm just curious i have 20
20 ethereum oh wow so that's like that
that's like what 35 000.
yeah and then mostly bitcoin so how many
bitcoins do you have
two ah that's these days that's worth a
lot of money
over a hundred grand yeah that's a
hundred g's can you tell us about like
how did
what do you do or how did you get into
all this stuff
how did you get the coins yeah
i just go to college but i like bought
it a long time ago
early adopter oh nice
got him when it was low that's so tell
me what did you buy these coins that's
what i kind of figured
i bought them for 500 bucks uh
each for the ethereum
oh that's pretty good i mean yeah it's
that's quadruple quadruple what'd you
get the bitcoin for
oh i mind it you mind it
how many [ __ ] graphics cards you got
over there
wow i just buy them all out from the
best buy
oh straight from best buy you're the
reason we don't have our new computer
dude you can mine it yourself yeah
anyone can mine it you just
so wait are you mining it right now you
still mining oh yeah
oh yeah baby we love it we got a miner
here
what's your setup what's your mining rig
yeah
i just got tons of new nvidia graphics
cards dude you're such a piece of [ __ ]
we've been waiting two months for just
one [ __ ] car so we can improve our
show
what do you say about that
uh you gotta just check stack x then oh
stop
what you were buying cards on stock
well oh another an illegal soul ladies
and gentlemen
ila sold and ila sold
[Music]
this guy is currently the top bid and he
owns two or
he has one ela coin he's also in the
discord as well
oh wow quite a community
well hey congratulations on being smart
and being an early adopter man
and now you're mining how much money do
you make mining like on a monthly
a basis dollars probably right now so
it's just a nice little
is that does that take in account your
costs your energy costs
right yeah okay so that's what you're
profiting
so do you still also need a job or is
this kind of like your thing
nah this is this is it that's so crazy
thousand dollars a month bro
how do you live at home with my parents
oh you live with your parents
do they know do they know that you're
doing that do they understand what you
do
yeah they want some of it too oh they
want to cut
interesting well dude you got a hundred
thousand dollars in your [ __ ]
wallet that's crazy money let me ask you
this
has it it must have gotten a lot harder
for you to make money because you have
two coins
but it sounds like at the rate you're
farming it's going up a lot slower
you're always slower
right so i think the unit coins
are going to sell out so you guys better
put in some offers
the ian ones you said i want
i gotta say that's kind of an
interesting play to buy out all the ians
because i wouldn't be surprised if you
started getting offers
because now you i mean you hold bro
you're you're holding
heavy yeah if anyone else sells those
ian ones i'm gonna buy them out too
you better make offers on those right
now start making offers you'll be the
sole holder and how much are you willing
to spend on the one of one gold coin
i am down to spend 10 ethereum
let's go
you shouldn't share that info though
well if the bidding's gonna get up there
it's one of one baby but i'm saying if
he shares that info like that's valuable
intel to others
yo and also do you care about the fact
that
there's the vape nation video attached
to it or do you just want the token
the vape nation video is the best part
of it that's what i figured i'm trying
to sell
the vape nation video but i don't know
is it two separate objects in or
or is it one object attached one right
yeah it's like attached there's like a
link to it i think
cool cool yeah
wow this is exciting this is gonna be an
exciting two weeks
well thank you so much man i appreciate
you coming out and supporting us and no
it's all only for two weeks going on
yeah they expire we've pledged to
destroy anything that doesn't sell
after two weeks and then the bid for the
golden
token one of one ends on
uh what in 13 13 days march 25th
at 12 a.m that's gonna be exciting dude
daddy's gonna get
paid i might get enough teeth too
so you gotta check out oh let's check
you out uh uh
what's the name no he just said it what
do you say it again
it's dark road like rhode island
dark road on what website
same website you guys use on openc
open c we're like searching for right
now let's see
it's music it's supposed to be like
music
all right we'll check it out i'm
clicking around
for life nation thanks for your support
buddy keep mining those coins all right
you mind those [ __ ] coins and you
better you tell your parents they don't
they don't they take their [ __ ] hands
off your damn coins
do they really want to cut how much they
want of your coins
like ten thousand dollars wow
that's okay i mean you live with is it
like a one-time payment or they want a
cut of all the action
i just sent you the link to his uh thing
and he wants one ian coin
so you're a musician and you sell your
music this way
you sell nfp are you going to claim us
for playing your music right now
please don't claim me bro this is my
dad's music
my dad's music huh how cool i
see like there's just so much going on
here yeah yep it's a whole ecosystem
well that's dark
roads on open sea all right
uh thank you for thank you for
participating man it's so nice to
to hear from you and to understand what
the hell's going on with this whole
crazy thing and uh i'm looking forward
to taking your tan ethereum in a couple
weeks
all right take care thanks for calling
thank you dude appreciate it
that's your man he's right this guy's
this guy's slick
dude i bet you one of those coins one of
those ian's is going to resell it's so
rare now
that's carlos this is feeling it
i'm feeling it i'm feeling it yeah your
art is really cool
why nobody want i feel like
such an opportunity here these people
they don't you see
is i don't know why these aren't sold
all of them there's such an opportunity
to make money
i feel like you're like i'm drinking the
kool-aid
yeah you need to chill daddy dude this
is
such a unique money-making opportunity
yeah
this is a once-in-a-lifetime
money-making opportunity
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
i love
this is
this is the best zach can we get some
daddy chills
yo like did they see it or did it we'd
lose it i wonder
oh i i caught it i caught it pretty much
as soon as it started to go down so
but yeah i think we're back no are we
oh i'm whatever i'm seeing it's a good
time to cut out
9 11. i just see money making
opportunity on the
all the bitcoin mining crash the server
yeah yeah we got a tweet with all those
with all those uh trending
hashtags dan uh
all right i got a jill there wait wait
wait
we're back we're back we're back we're
back okay
there's a listing for the ian for two
ethereum
somebody already re-listed it so
somebody's trying to oh because they
heard that guy was like i'm buying
it was the zom zombreeze dude oh that's
awesome
that was the one we just spoke to right
so he's trying to resell for two already
damn i thought he was holding
he's been talking to me in the discord
he's like i want to buy your tokens too
i think they're really nice i'm like no
no man you don't have to no that was
before he called in but now that he
called in
feel free
yeah sure enough i see that now when you
look at the listing on your hands it
says price two
yo this is the free market baby
someone's reselling ian for two let's
see if somebody buys it oh
that'll be wild there's so many great
tokens to buy you can get for one
for example the vape nation
for example all right we're gonna wrap
it up this was fun though
all right this is it guys
what can i say it's friday
[Music]
keep your mask on and your head low
we're all going to get vaccinated in may
according to
joe biden
[Music]
joe biden wait you're watching
joe biden give me that [ __ ]
oh i want that covert shop i'll take the
pfizer i'll take the other one that i
can't say i'll take the johnson johnson
give me everything you're a bad boy john
joe bison
wake up did you have fun elias nice
having you here on friday
yeah what was your favorite part of the
show today
actually i got i have to admit that the
wearing the suits i really i thought you
hated it
i didn't hate it it was interesting it
was interesting and not too offensive it
wasn't like
so viscerally effect like eating meat is
slightly weird
yeah just kind of interesting and fun
did you like part where you flipped it
i don't think i saw that we didn't show
it i could show that to you
did you like the part where he peed his
pants they didn't see that part that one
was weird
oh there it is
all right guys have a great weekend
we'll be back on tuesday with frenemies
or monday if you remember
you know what it is what are we going to
get what do you want to eat
i will tell you all about it off the air
you'll see
the best podcasts in the world
right it's like good it's like good
we're ending the show
chit-chat you're checking your phone
yeah so we're wrapping up like new
zealand okay you could be like playing
the music
and fading bye-bye bye-bye
my drinks are made while the incest on
the sleep shredder would stop bopping
off freighters at the suite
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
and e.t
share with laughs with the ring just see
y'all love jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do rice from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h2 three three three
three you're watching h two
three three three three you're watching
h two three three three three
you're watching h two three three three
taking us out have a good one everybody